foreign
hello
[Music]
how do I get rid of this okay there we
go
what up chat
[Music]
all right
foreign
what's up how you guys doing
[Music]
oh yeah okay
let's get it going
on
this this might take the entire day okay
like we might be here for like eight to
ten hours I have no idea how long this
is gonna take but
[Music]
welcome
to our first challenge run kind of not
our first but it's you know it's what
we're doing since we hit a hundred
members
as you can see we're well over a hundred
now because you guys are freaking nuts
from yesterday
but
today we're gonna do something a little
bit crazy something I actually have not
seen before
I think it kind of speaks for itself but
if you don't understand it I'll explain
it really quick
for every level
that we want to go up in in the game
we are going to spin the wheel that you
can see in the bottom right corner
whatever it lands on
I have to upgrade that attribute
makes sense
here's how it works I click it
it spins
it lands on something
we'd level int
makes sense
it's pretty easy to understand
one question I have
for you all
is let's say we beat a demigod and got
50 000 runes
and let's say we got 10 levels out of
that as an example
I'm I think I should let which or not
twitch not twitch I should let chat
decide
if we spent like we spin it and all of
those levels go into one thing that it
lands on or we do 10 individual spins
that was my only question
and that would kind of avoid a mundane
build
if we do that and maybe we don't do that
every time but what what do you guys
think
would you kindly repeat it please
no I don't repeat myself
by the way we have two new emotes
um yesterday we unlocked 18 slots so we
have to come up with emote ideas okay
because you guys are nuts we have the
giga
the Giga chat is in
it is here
and we also have
stare because I do this a lot
okay
so enjoy those
uh we we literally have 18 others to
fill
so if you guys want stuff let me know in
the Discord okay
I say do it one by one if you guys want
one by one that's fine it's not hard to
do I was just curious to what you would
want to do
um as for a starting class I feel like
wretch is the only viable thing to do in
this right
since it's like bass you know I mean
or
should we spin for it
[Music]
that means I have to redo the wheel
okay we'll do one by one
you want me to cosplay a wretched so you
want me to stream in my underwear
uh hello thousand members
thousand thousand yo what up fiction
welcome back to the tarnish man good to
have you brother what up what up what up
thank you thank you this is gonna take
forever yeah
you're right so we need to get on it now
let's just do wretch because I don't
want to redo the the thing
I don't want to redo it
what is our name
easy
spinny
easy name
okay and then I'm just gonna do golden
seed
S
as family
it's an honor seeing you do a challenge
I came up with wish you luck
guys red potato is the one that came up
with this challenge so everyone W's and
chat for Mr Potato I appreciate it very
much and thank you for the five dollars
I really appreciate it I think we gotta
be spinny
and we're gonna be Giga for the new
emote okay
I think that's just a fake like all this
matches up perfectly
spinny
giga
wretch
let's go
let's do it
we gotta get going baby
it's going to be great when you get 20
mind and no Vigor listen
don't don't give the stream bad vibes
already okay
don't don't do that
I believe in energy and spirit energy
and you gotta have all Positive Vibes
all right
great I got my water for the day
oh [ __ ] I have to drink all this during
the stream so there there might be some
potty breaks
across the fog
lands
yummy
no 24 hour stream in America the Eternal
I've done a 24-hour stream once on
Twitch
it was awful
I'd do it though
Godwin the golden
was fuss yeah let's see if we get the
250 members okay that's when we'll do a
drunk stream
that sounds fun
America's Offspring also I have to watch
the intro I never ever skip the intro
they just don't do it no cheating on the
wheel I mean I'm literally streaming the
entire thing so I don't know how I could
cheat let me get rid of that for now
my taint of the Newfound strength
record
I'm a hydrated tarnished tarnished
drunk Galore hunting from which
that sounds awful that that sounds like
you guys will be so annoyed with me
oh
leading to that was Twitch in the past
this is YouTube now
has anyone on YouTube done a 24-hour
stream
Ludwig Ludwig right now
you dead oh yeah live
yeah do we know who this narrator is
speaks to us all
watch it be radagon
[Music]
Chieftain of the Badlands
[Music]
they all knowing okay let's see if my
game glitches out
sometimes
and this scene the colors will be
distorted
we're good
no Distortion this time
and one one other
oh Grace would again bless you guys
think we're in the
top it looks like inside the earth tree
it looks like inside the earth tree
while my back is so hairy oh my God
cross the fog
to the lands between
but I think it's like you're not
physically inside the earth tree but
your spirit is like yeah before I talked
about it
in the tarnished video from a couple
weeks ago you should go watch it
and become the Elden Lord
oh
um
it looks very similar
same bright white light
all right guys let's go let's do this we
we are not [ __ ] around today okay
we go hard we go fast
we go hard we go fast
we finish quick
just like your sex life
let's go
look at that ass
look at that giga
[Music]
I think I care if I die here I don't
but I will fight you
there it is
it's a good try
I didn't try that hard action one thank
you welcome to the tarnish
appreciate it enjoy the emotes
make sure to join the Discord and
everything welcome welcome
look at you guys actually using emotes
you guys are you're making me proud
a proud streamer right now
real question would you what okay let me
read that in my head first
never mind
not worth
bigger check
now we can all Spam the you died
maybe it's more fun when a lot of people
actually have the emotes you know
is there a chance of every stat being
the same
yeah
there is
don't worry torrent
Fortune
with the five gifted
let's go after all
thank you man
I appreciate that
let's go up so it's gonna say wait I
could not fix this by the way I could
not fix it it's unfixable so it's gonna
tell us every single person that got a
gifted
so I made the alert less obnoxious
so thank you Ludwig I appreciate you man
thank you thank you
I learned more about uh gifted
memberships here too okay
I learned more the more you talk in chat
and are a part of the community
like if you like the stream if you're
subscribed if you you know watch the
stream a lot you have a better chance of
getting a gifted membership
Isn't that cool
now that does not tell you to spam
because I'll ban you and then you won't
get [ __ ]
all right
that was pretty cool
so thank you again Ludwig
all right guys
I think we go beat up Rick for the for
the potential for a level what do you
think
we gotta go beat up Rick real quick
I don't wanna no we're we're saving them
for the end game
yes on the uh Wizards wizard run we
let's let's go beat the [ __ ] out of him
okay
I need all the runes I can get
these guys give me 14.
correct he's a false god we're gonna go
beat up an illusion of Rick
the last boss already
yep you know you know what I did last
night just to fall asleep too
I watched a bunch of streamers
in their first playthrough of Eldon ring
it was really fun to watch
I wish I could go back and play it again
for the first time
what did Rick do to you everything Rick
John Rick is everything Rick is the only
reason that we're here
he is the god of gods he's the god to
the greater will it's all his fault
so I'm gonna go beat up his illusion
that's meant to give us a false sense of
reality
on how strong we actually are
and thank you for the two dollar Super
Chat
like a fart in the Wind
not even relevant
straight
hopefully we get a lot of that today
that's our streamer
I just beat up the God of Gods
although
in the lore
it's not really him
he's holding back it's sad
it actually hurts my feelings
to know the lore
it's okay
he went easy on you he didn't even try
didn't even try
I've been watching aegon of astorious
play through and he made a terrible
mistake of turning off tutorial messages
30 hours in he's still not figured out
how to equip a talisman
so that's telling me that he's never
played a Souls game before right
all right do I go try and beat the tree
Sentinel
or would you consider that a waste of
time
it could be a waste of time or a three
easy three piece
an easy 3K
technically really hard 3K
like am I skilled enough he's played
every Souls game but he doesn't know
about talismans
what a dork
I can do this
I got lucky
you can do this
no I can't no I can't
foreign
I thought I jumped over it
I can do it though
do we continue to waste our time on this
God damn it I can do it I believe in
myself
uh it feels good to have people actually
use emotes
forgot what this feeling was like
zaida
let's go
W's in the chat
W's look at this
okay that was three misses ignore that
appreciate you
let me get my runes back [ __ ]
foreign
we need these runes
we need them
I got stuck by dude
this movement is not ideal
good hit
foreign we just got super lucky just now
let's freaking go baby come on
okay I should not go for that
not worth
oh this is it this is the Run
[Music]
remember when I said I shouldn't do that
I did it again
no
we're good
it's like it never happened
what'd you find Logan
what up bro
thank you for the five
no
he's spamming brood he's cheating
I can do this I can do it I can do it
for sure
I'm scared man
break
I'm literally throwing
I don't even know what's happening I
gotta Focus I gotta Focus
come on Jake
what
wait what's going on
wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what's going on us
more members
blade of Me Okay Logan gifted 10 members
after Zeta gifted five
thank you very much and then GB coming
in with another 10.
all I'm doing is dying
I feel like I shouldn't have got hit by
that I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead and
say it
more members that's what you found from
the gym okay Logan thank you man I
appreciate all the support GB Zeta Logan
thank you guys very much thank you thank
you
if you got a gifted make sure to say
thank you
and then uh join the Discord join the
Discord like the Stream
all the [ __ ] I guys I I definitely feel
like I can do this
I definitely feel like I can
I don't want this to take that long
though
[Music]
I had it I had it there too and I threw
[Music]
press one if I threw that last that last
try
yeah
currently throwing
currently throwing all right listen
did I get Rick's runes back
okay I like this
I like the lighting around here right
now this is a good vibe we got it this
try this is the one
hundred percent
foreign
here we go
foreign
foreign
that was a really bad time to do that
really bad
like I said
bad time to do that
guys my my confidence was like peaking
on that good attempt and now it's gone
gone
I feel like I have to do it though
four attacks right there he went for
four attacks
because he does one
depends on his mood
what
dude I I'm like literally in a tree okay
that wasn't my fault
it might have been
foreign
that
sweep across is insane it it'll go it it
reaches back
so far
but what do I gotta do
I gotta get good and not die
that's how this game works
foreign
dude he's being so annoying
Focus up
you like that
I don't like that
I felt like I was a decent distance
this is my last attempt if I don't get
it I'll probably try again
Maybe
no pressure
foreign
I'm gonna keep trying because Steven
tells me to keep moving on
it's the only reason
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
ah
he whipped that out
like it was nothing I was farming him
right there
I was farming him dude
oh my God
farming
foreign
guys this is the challenge before the
challenge
okay
you gotta get ruined somehow guys
huh
I thought he'd stagger I thought he'd
staggered
foreign
foreign
foreign
that was so easy imagine if we listened
to Steven though
haha
he says finally all right [ __ ] you
be drunk guy we I'm not drunk I have not
been drinking
at all
that's the 250 member stream this is the
100 member stream
look at that you guys remember eight
months ago
that uh
[ __ ] uh
like a bunch of streamers tried to do
that for like six hours and none of them
could do it anyone remember that stream
I think it was literally on YouTube too
I didn't like what 15 minutes
15 minutes
all right here we go wait I can't even
level yet why'd I do that
okay
let's go get torrent and [ __ ]
I just want pay to become a member
uh there's a link in the description or
it'll say join right next to subscribe
for the lows that was pretty fun and
pretty Epic
when are you gonna go when are you gonna
do gonna be what did you what yeah but
when you
I'm so [ __ ] dyslexic yeah but when
you do you gonna be super drunk through
yes it's a monthly subscription
buy the kit
that
I'm not gonna lie
I don't think I have ever
used the crafting kit
maybe once for Alexander's questline
we got a douse him in oil
I don't know Lord Farquaad ask [ __ ]
YouTube bro
yeah it's for Sleep pots
okay I wasted a lot of time we got to
skip this [ __ ] you all know about Melina
she's she's a homie have you heard head
of the finger maidens he's looking at
how vascular I am I can play turning to
age yet you need to the foot okay here
we go
we're gonna do the challenge let's see
what we're gonna start off with all
right wait let me pop one of these bad
boys
here we go
here's the whole challenge
let's bring out the spinny boy bam
all right you guys said we can level
five times so you guys are seeing five
spins or one spin for all five levels
what do you want to do everyone at the
beginning said
one spin for each level which we can do
you want five spins all right here we go
first level
please go to Vigor go to Vigor go to
Vigor go to vigor
[Applause]
it's gonna be that kind of [ __ ] day
man I am telling you it's it's gonna be
this
it's gonna give me [ __ ] Arcane which
isn't that bad I don't I don't know why
I'm mad
spin number two
okay
okay
[Applause]
decks
that's fine
I'm okay with that
spin number three
I thought it went to mind bro let's go
let's go baby
Mr G
Mr GB are you give can you gift certain
people is that what you're doing or is
are these just coming in late
so there you go Lord Farquaad you just
got gifted a membership let's go thank
you man
thank you GB okay uh spin number four
right
yeah
here we go
here we go
all right
that's kind of a waste but it's okay
these are all going into different
things
in last spin
go go go go go all right
there it is guys all right well
excellent excellent good I just gave the
10 I think it's random okay gotcha
thank you again man
yeah redovia it is
rivers of blood Draven Dragon Magic
can we go get the reduvia
reduvia hello
yeah why are these all coming in so late
well thank you for all the gifted guys
thank you thank you all right would you
guys call that W spins or L spins
let's see
let me let me go up here
will you respect with the wheel no there
is no respeking
that would defeat the entire purpose
it was kind of meh right
a mid-spin yeah
this does this is pretty fun actually
however the the two we got out of that
were both were two arcanes
I have not done Arcane before to be
honest with you
but maybe it's better than I think
it's a great starter blade
I feel like I should get some clothes
right
you're willing to make me a chrysalid
this ain't a lore run
I'm out here bonkin [ __ ] okay let's
get some upgrades
foreign
I thought Arcane was like a meme
Maybe I'm Wrong
since they like nerfed bleed and
everything
yeah I bonked I bonked her
I did it
foreign
let's go I'm just getting all these
upgrade materials we're gonna need all
this stuff for whatever we decide to do
with this freaking build
I've watched all of your vods in the
last couple months it's helped me a lot
with feeling lonely in a new city with a
few friends oh thank you you're welcome
man I'm glad I can help in any way I can
I've been lonely in a new city before
too I've lived in Orlando Miami and
Arizona some parts of California all by
myself it's hard man but I'm glad I can
help
glad I can help in any way I possibly
can
thank you for the five I appreciate it
I'm debating on getting the Uchi Katana
should I go get it
it's in that cave
hello shut up Alexander can you hear me
oh it's not Nerf for PVE that's right
that's true
get it
the ash of War on that thing guys is
well can I even use it
I don't think I can use it I mean might
as well get it right yeah
might as well get it
can you hear me help me dude I love that
you guys are using emotes now that makes
me so happy
don't become like twitch chat though
okay your YouTube chat become your own
thing
you guys are more sophisticated okay
I've been in La for three years now
moved here in covid so I'm now starting
to get an actual social life I feel that
man I feel that
well hopefully it's going better now
I went to LA earlier this year to see a
friend oh my god did I dislike La a lot
oh my God I disliked it
foreign
I was not a fan
I might never go back there
are you gonna be using talents that
boost attributes
I mean I probably should right
or if you guys ban that I won't use it
it's up to you though
oh we're going as fast as possible
I'm gonna try and do this challenge
today
it's a miserable place to live I mean I
visited and had a miserable time so well
I had fun with my friend
but uh I did not like the city
should I try and beat this boss
foreign
the answer is yes
wait what is this boss it's a black
knife assassin with a little bit of
health gone
this is gonna be hard but it's
definitely doable
re
EF
foreign
you're so fast
I can't even see her
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
not good
get a lantern sure let me fart that out
of my ass real quick
foreign
get her in a corner
there we go
easy peasy
might as well all right
good stuff good stuff boys
I don't know what we did that for for
the runes obviously
I saw you've lived in Orlando I live in
Orlando I like Orlando it I liked
Orlando I did not like Miami I did not
like La I loved Arizona I would probably
live in Arizona again
um but I'm here in Missouri
being a forehead all right
I think I got a bunch of a bunch of
these yeah let's let's pop all these and
then we'll we'll do some more spinny
boys
we'll do some spinny spins
well let's see if we can even use the
Uchi after this
it's a theme park parking lot whoa okay
you should move to Sweden my goal is to
live in Norway by the time I'm 35.
that's literally a life goal that I have
planned in my head
all right you guys ready we're gonna do
some more spinny spins
here we go
please give me vigor
please don't let this be an Arcane build
with no Vigor bro we'll be here for days
okay
here we go we've got
six spins six spins one
here's the first spin
that's fine that's fine
I'm I'm okay with that that's good for
Ash is a war let's go with that okay
spin number two
it's good for Ash's War right
okay baby
that's what I'm used to I love strength
let's go all these attributes are going
into whatever they're everywhere man
spin number three
go go go go go go go go go go go go okay
I'm cool with that all right all right
okay spin number four
little endurance in there that that's
always good right
a little bit more straight okay
strength build chat strength build
okay
is this last spin
go go go
I love how Vigor and Arcane are right
next to each other
let's go that's huge for the build
absolutely massive okay we have one more
let's go
give me the decks let's go okay
good spins
that was a w span guys that was huge
I'm cool with pretty much all that all
right
I think I can use the Uchi
I can't wait I can dual wield it right I
need 15 decks to use the Uchi
but it works if I do this right
I should know this stuff and I'm never
entirely sure
okay
let's go get the reduvia
let's do it
that's a real wheel looks like the app
one my daughter has
dude it's such a cute wheel
get Millicent prosthesis talisman
let me just go fart that out of my ass
like I said real quick let me just go to
Caleb and get that okay
or actually let me just go to complete
her entire questline real quick
or no
I don't remember
die should know that I should
no only strength if you double hand oh
that's right okay well we're going back
to the bonkers
back to the bonkers
get the source seal are you guys okay
with me using talismans that make me
that change my attributes
or should for this challenge have that
not be a thing
I will do whatever the chat wants to do
hi Trey
no actually let's put it to a vote
because we can do that
um
I'm just going to call it leveling
talismans
question mark
yes or no leveling I spelled talisman's
wrong but [ __ ] it you guys know what I
mean yes or no
let's run a poll
I forgot we had this
basically if you're cool with it or not
I'll run that for a little bit
or should it just be a full level with
the spinny wheel build
get your votes in get your votes in
where's my sound keep cutting out
all right you guys seem pretty adamant
about yes
75 yes I'm actually surprised
that's surprising
y'all are terrorists where did that
comment come from
foreign
I'm dead
I should be dead I need to let Euro take
care of this
if it is hilarious
the bloody finger the end is nigh
for you
bruh that came out so fast
okay
yeah he can just whip that thing around
like it's no one's business dude
get out get out get Jake
I was trying to roll and I'm pretty sure
I was stuck on a tree
all right all right Iris I respect the
pole
that's very kind of you guys
I can use leveling talismans
like the source seals
would be unfair to rule out talismans
they also have a drawback
crew good point I forgot about the
drawback
better than Elon do you guys think our
spinny wheel build will be better than
Elon Musk build
that was quite frankly the worst thing
I've ever seen in my life
yeah you're kind of right Stephen okay
we'll get it
you got you guys are very
smart you're very understandable I feel
like if I was doing this on Twitch
they'd be like no
you're also not allowed to see you gotta
turn your monitor off too bro
[Music]
they would because they're like [ __ ]
12.
just look up the Elon build it's awful
yeah dude
are you kidding
God yeah we need to get that reduvia huh
where's Europe
he's all the way over there what
he always comes from this side
hey
I did
foreign
oh man
foreign
it'll just be a good option to have
right
finish him let's go
good stuff
oh maybe with the scars sorcelia let's
see
13 decks 13 Arcane that's not bad and
we're actually pretty close to that
we're already at 12. we need one more
attribute in Arcane and decks and we're
good holy [ __ ]
let's go that's big
now
can I kill patches
can I murder his ass for runes
I need runes
any other class you can use it now the
arc is a hard part yeah
time to kill patches
please kill patches oh a plus eight
spear too good point
I forgot about that
eat I'm also still naked
this is close
it's not very good close but
look at us go
cough up your coins
wait he's still behind the shield when
he holds it up oh [ __ ]
man man
I surrender white flag and all
but he has more than one we're about to
make out like Bandits boys I've always
killed him by now
oh okay
okay he's out
he's out
what a hit
he's not easy when you can't just kill
him immediately
it was bound to happen something
what a [ __ ] shoot
all right we got good armor from that
guys that was totally worth it that was
Totes My Goats worth it
yep
rip Bozo in the chat rip Bozo okay
now we've got a little bit more runes
let's do some more spinny spins
if we can level
lost another 10 cool points
what
10 points
all right let's see how many we got we
might not actually have a level
we have two I'm an idiot okay spinny
spin time two levels
I'm in hot
okay
mostly gotten strength so far
it's big I'm cool with strength man
I'm cool with it I have a lot of
experience in that are we gonna get our
decks
let's go
are we like doing good oh [ __ ] my bad I
didn't turn it on
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
okay well that one actually hit Dex
can I show you oh I can look look
I don't want to be like lying uh how can
I show you like this
wait wait
no I'm not spinning again look it tells
you
what the last few spins have been right
there
you see that so we just got decks and
right before it was strength
is that fair
the
I know you can see the decks
right there it says scr Str strength
Dex
decks before that see we even have a
whole ass list
but I forgot to pull it up my bed
that's my bad yeah
Steven
has just
he has good comments in the bad comments
I'll just point that out
okay
so we're good with this fair and legit
okay thank you
I don't want to scam anybody
I'm your friend hey man make better
comments you know
make better comments dude that's all I
gotta say
that's good this school
this equal
see I even provided proof can you think
of another streamer that would provide
proof probably
okay
I'm trying to think of the best course
of action
we should probably go down here and get
all the uh yeah that's what we're gonna
do
we can kill
the the big troll
and we can get a bunch of craft uh
upgrade materials
streams are considered proof well I mean
this for this that's a little different
later guys I'm kidding calm
[Music]
Kong one
hi Pedro
foreign
oh we should go get flask upgrades too
I always forget about Flash upgrades
really do
which is like really important
how many levels do we need to level 1445
Stoke for the drunk stream hey
we gotta get there first
we need uh 42 more subs
and then we'll do a drunk stream
have you noticed all in quest lines in
bed
is Elven ring your first Souls game
is it your first
I think all quest lines in all of their
previous games in bed
foreign
all of them
is there good any good ending to some
plus lines
oh boy
what
I'm gonna die some rats okay there we go
box can be
you're not wrong but have you seen the
other ending
foreign
the jellyfish
would you consider the jellyfish thing
to be a quest line
yeah
yeah
Ronnie's questline did you see what
happens to EG and blyde
I mean [ __ ] dude
I wouldn't call that necessarily good
Ryan's doesn't end well
does it
I don't want to go over this direction
I'm gonna die
Yep Hot town is sad
uh-oh
foreign
depends a lot of it depends what happens
to blight and EG
nobody tell him
don't ruin his day
yeah box is okay
foreign
this might have been like a bad way to
go about this
uh
we're gonna keep going
Heights in the fellies those in well I
guess you're right
through
all right we're gonna do this
like this
honestly because I'm gonna knock them
over over and over again
the art NASA here from software creates
is unparalleled
ax
foreign
this is not going as well as I wanted to
it's going as well as I wanted to now
easy peasy baby easy peasy
it's enough for a level
got him like the brownies in the okay
gosstuck never ends well for me I always
kill that bastard I mean you can leave
them yeah for you yeah okay
I see what you're saying
imagine how annoying you are to him a
weird naked dude smacking the [ __ ] out
of his feet at least I'm not naked I get
your point though true
okay
two more
I will pull it up this time so you guys
don't be all weird be like he's cheating
okay
let's go
this is quickly turning into a strength
to build
it's happening
all right we got one more
strengthen decks
I'm fine with it
this is good
all right awesome
there we go
those little you know we we're a little
low on health
uh which is concerning we're gonna be
okay
the strength follows Jake I guess so man
I guess so
shut up Fox
this is not as bad as it appeared to be
yeah but imagine it like
it only did arcane through the whole
game
I mean I guess there's like a very low
chance of that happening but it could
happen
you know what I mean
turn into a no hit run at this rate
I want to start doing that
I don't think I'd be very good at it
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to study the no
hit run and see if it's something that
we could practice and maybe do it
someday
64 Arcane and 16 strength
it could happen
you can use Uchi now
not quiet I need
one more decks
so that's close
our chances for a couple of good weapons
are really good
um
I mean uh
I could go kill bloodhound
I think we'll be okay without it though
debating debating debating debating
the baby the baby the baby the baby
let's go get our upgrades
the reduvia
no I need one more Arcane for that
who kills EG and blind
honestly good question
now you know they're dead I guess I
can't spoil it for you
um black knife assassins kill EG blyde
we kill blood
we kill blood
I'm sorry to tell you
okay her questline is worthless to us
so [ __ ] her
try the large Club
oh I mean you know if that's something
we want to get later on then we can
yeah
you still only use Uchi in this game I
don't know where to get the bleed katana
the uh
rivers of blood is in the mountaintops
of the Giants and you have to kill an
NPC to get it
yeah blood kills the Assassins that try
to kill him he goes insane and then we
kill him
[Music]
yeah blind
has a lot of comparisons to guts
use blackplay magic I know I was saying
EG killed the assassins
what
well yeah they're all dead true I just
thought he lost to him
there are a lot of dead assassins around
them
at the end
I always assume that he died to the
black magic
but he used Blackmagic is what you're
saying
what does Arcane actually do for you in
this game let's read
uh help
explanation
attribute governing discovery
also affects holy defense vitality and
certain sorceries and incantations
there you go now you know
it's like the luck stat
foreign
hi Joe how are you
[Music]
we're just getting some upgrades and
then I think
I think we can kill the archery Avatar
up here
but it helps you it it compares to bleed
and dragon builds yeah
like it uh
unlocks the attributes for that that's
where the attributes usually correspond
to
black flame killed EG that's why some
believe there were God skin alongside
the Black Knight assassins that's what I
always thought
or
am I weird for saying that I think the
glomide queen killed him
who's technically Melina
foreign
might be a little weird for that but
that's kind of where my head goes when I
think of that
the night of Long Knives
I don't know what that is
playing Horizon forbidden West
I hope you find the game fun I did not
Rena
definitely don't know that one
two fingers killed them
at that point in the game the two
fingers is not even a factor
they're like conversing with the greater
will for 10 000 years or something
1934.
they found out what Ronnie was up to
they always knew what Ronnie was up to
why am I being blocked in the chat
you're not what do you mean you're not
blocked
all right
someone already said it night of black
knives oh oh
SS took 150 members of leadership in
1934 to take over and give Hitler power
that's a well I don't know anything
about that but sounds similar I have no
idea
okay we got those let's go try and kill
the Earth tree Avatar I'm pretty sure we
can
YouTube keeps saying the service is
unavailable it's just YouTube not the
channel
what service
what are you talking about
what's going on
was God's gonna have to do with black
knife assassins
uh glomide Queen
could have something to do with that
we're just talking about black knife
assassins because there's a bunch of
them dead around EG when we find him
dead and then he's on fire with black
Flame
kitchen knife assassins
what service but I think that's why they
think they're blocked from chat
I have no idea what you guys are talking
about right now
what
foreign
[Music]
not good timing
foreign
words of Rena what
oh [ __ ]
yeah I need a boost
is this a roar thing chat because I have
that talisman
[Music]
I mean it's called barbaric Roar
oh my God
I'm gonna die
oh man
I shall soon enter a slumber and it will
be some time before I wake the doll's
body is not hendritious still I have
high hopes for thee I look forward to
the good news when I arise what does
that have to do with blyde and EG being
dead
also that's Ronnie not Rena what I'm
confused so I'm confused
okay
let's go do more spinny spins got any
plans for upcoming lore videos or
hunting anytime soon not right now
um I mean I have a lot of them there's
tons of things we could do but
I'm focused on streaming right now
okay we got two more spinny spins
okay
two more we really want arcane
Arcane would be big
endurance all right all right
[Applause]
what's the other one we want Dex
oh oh
whoa
[Music]
that was a close one that was like
basically a tie between decks and
strength nice okay
sweet keep it going
the Talisman should work let's go
I mean am I gonna use it anymore I can
use the Uchi and I can use the spear
160 115.
should we try out this spear
[Music]
hmm
the glomide queen could have used Ronnie
with the black knives then turned on her
tried to eliminate her after the royal
family was ruined
why would the glomide queen care about
that
well actually maybe
we can get a lore chat well I I don't
know what
never mind
the quotes you were saying I don't know
what that would have to do with anything
that we were talking about okay I'll use
the spear for a while because we use the
Uchi before
I think we could be Market at this point
right
I think we can
it'd be funny to have a weapon wheelie
to spin before boss fights
bro
you think EG knew they were being hunted
and that's why he put blyden in ever
jail to protect his friend
I don't think so because he put him in
the ever jail
because he knew he was gonna go insane
and then we let him out
ooh am I allowed to use it let me let me
try this out real quick
okay
no I won't use a summon
why did he go insane because he's a
shadow
and
the greater will finally found out what
Ronnie was doing and
Shadows come from the greater will
they're given to imperience so blight is
given to Ronnie
embolden by the frame of ambition
um eventually he was taken over he I
don't there's Bly did not want to attack
us or hurt Ronnie in any way but he he
was taken over he went berserk
foreign
left and he found out the greater will
found out what Ronnie was doing
obviously and then
it takes over blood
not a good start
why are your delays so much more right
now
foreign
God damn put that [ __ ] blade away
[Music]
not very good chat
Warrior blood must truly run in my veins
oh my God
come on
I didn't have any stamina
damn it
I don't think he took over blide I'm
pretty sure EG says exactly that
that the greater will will take his like
I'm not saying the greater will is
physically taking him over but his true
nature reveals itself he's literally
manifested from the greater will as a
shadow for Ronnie
so of course he's going to get taken
over if you get what I mean by that
what's another way to put it
yeah I can use the uchikatana but I'm
trying the spear
foreign
I just have to wave
God
put These Foolish Ambitions to rest
I've never seen him do that before
that was a weird spin I don't like spear
chat
I'm not a fan of it let's try the katana
right
foreign
I got stuck on a sword
I think I can get this out yep
knew it
gets strength idiot
foreign
although we're not going to be able to
use unsheath in a second
tarnish
solid
feel like bleed is pretty good
I don't think blyde was made by the
greater will it's literally stated that
he is
you goofballs
man dude this is why I get so confused
but from comets that started this like
it's it's I I never mind
I'm just saying that's why I get
confused there's a reason you think that
but man
forgive me Hernandez I've been testing
you to see whether or not Grace truly
does guide you and
whether you are fit to face the
challenge and we can go to the Round
Table
it seems my worries were unfounded
torrent by who you'll measure from the
very start I don't remember exactly it's
EG right EG says that Glide was created
by the greater will it says it in some
description of it can take you to the
round Imperium Shadows somewhere I don't
remember exactly the places but that's
been a well-known thing I did it's like
how malachath is to America right very
well let my hand rest
malacath is Queen America's Shadow blide
is Ronnie's shadow
[Music]
player player only good spear is a
halberd yeah
I like Halfords halberts are fun I don't
know if I like that spear very much
though
yeah I think it's dialogue by EG I think
it's so no you didn't want you I'm sorry
I'm sorry you're fine Joe you're fine
you're fine all I'm saying is dude
that's why I stopped watching other
Elden ring content creators it's why I
stopped reading 99 of my comments in any
of my videos is because dude some people
would just
I'm not saying you drive me insane Joe
but it's just like those things make me
question what I think
and then I'll spend like a whole [ __ ]
day trying to
like
know like I don't know how to put it I'm
weird like that where I'll believe
anything you guys tell me
I'm so [ __ ] gullible dude no matter
but I I know blight is made from the
greater will
I'm gonna put that out there
okay
let's do some more spinny spins because
I think we can do a lot
okay
it messes with my perception my
perspective I'm the most gullible guy in
the world in the world chat so that's
why I feel that way
you need a wheel weapon from volcano
Mana for the Ultimate Wheel build
if I got wheel permits it oh I like that
idea potatoes got all the good ideas man
and thank you for the five dollar Super
Chat I appreciate that that's a good
idea
if it comes down to it that we can use
it I'll give it a shot if it if it's
good then
we'll see we gotta get there first
that's gonna be a while from now
all right guys we got four Smitty spins
that's a really good idea though okay
four spinny spins
one
I wouldn't mind arcane
this is actually becoming a strength
build
man
all right
all right
and also you guys said Arcane was like
are the reduvius good early right
wait did I pull it up on screen okay
good
int
we got two more two more spinny spins
um
is there strength int is that a thing
oh don't throw faith in there bro that's
the first first faith that we've gotten
that seems like a waste at this point
last one I think yep
mind this is okay yeah we can do a
blinds blade is that mine all right got
it
yeah this build is weird
[Music]
this is just like everything up a little
bit at this point
with strength index kind of going out a
little bit more okay
I'm gonna upgrade my Uchi and use that
for a while
because you know the fact that we can
use the Uchi is pretty good
Royal Greatsword Pearl knight sword
right well I'll just eat my match
bang bang bang bang
[Music]
let's go
there'll be a level limit no
we go crazy out here bro
all right let's go kill godric
go fast go quick go hard why not spin to
see what weapon to upgrade
come on dude don't make it that crazy
I guess this is gonna be a quality build
right
falling star Beast jaw oh moon Veil
oh yeah
wheel off for now
gar sir did there's no way we can put
enough points into something specific I
it's
I think this is going to be a quality
building
come over here we have like a little bit
of everything
but of course raging wolf wanted to
become the shadow of the glomide queen
who is also an empyrean
so there's got to be some way to become
a shadow
of course I am
it says that the Raging wolf wanted to
become a shadow
where does it say that
because that would to become wanting to
become the shadow
I mean what if it's not becoming a
shadow
what if it's like you defeat
what if it's like you defeat their
Shadow or something
then you can become the shadow
so there's like the shadow that's
created by the greater will
or it's given if you can defeat him
something like that
I can't [ __ ] see
well they're all shooting at different
times
dude I've never been hit here before
my God
sometimes the translations are off
yeah but if we thought that then we'd
have to think that for everything
which is
I don't think we can do that you know
I think it's weird all the demigods with
r have the first leg with their name
kind of crazy
um
all the demigods
I mean
Piccolo
Melania
[ __ ]
I don't know I'm blinking right now
but yeah most of them are radon Ronnie
Reichard
there's more well morgon MOG aren't are
they technically demigods yes
let me up here thank you
godric
Godwin
all the ones from radagon and Ronaldo
start with an R
oh this is a little crazy
oh God
oh my God
hey God cream
Godfrey's technically not a demigod that
is true
he's of distant relation and disliked by
literally everyone
it's like a like a half breed something
like that
Ronaldo's not a demigod
well now we're talking about imperience
not demigods
radon is a demigod but he is not an
imperian does that make sense
cannot become an empyrean
bump I don't even know what this is
yeah I just wanted to do that
yeah to pay tribute to George RR Martin
That's the theory you know uh we don't
know that for sure but it kind of looks
like it
technically he's the guy that wrote the
story so I guess it's possible that he
was like I'm just gonna do George RR
Martin
oh my goodness
I'm related to rent a cop
right right
you start with an R
okay who am I related to
nobody
Jake
are there any other like characters in
the game that start with a j
I don't even want this
it could be good to have
now I'm never gonna use that
you are related to Bobby
my dad a demigod
Juno oh God
Oslo hell no
Bobby
where was Godfrey in the time where we
don't fight against him like bro I
killed all your children do something
I gotta think that he wasn't alive
stop us yet like he wasn't giving Grace
back because I think he I think he's
dead in the lands between that's my
theory or in the Badlands I think he's
dead
to me when I see the his painting at the
the beginning cut scene he looks hung up
and dead and then he's given Grace back
porn air
thy strength o kindred
deliver me unto
straighter Heights
press one and chat if the lore in this
game is pretty cool but also really
complicated
I'm related to jar Barn I'm cool with
that
playing as a lord
I command these
I am the Lord of all that is golden
do you know Japanese GB
I'm not gonna learn Japanese to
understand this game I'm not gonna do it
I'm sorry guys I will not go that far
I should have added another blue flask
gotcha everyone has potato
what everything means
he's got it
got the bleed
okay
there's a lot of
Shaquille
yes the main story of Eldon ring is not
complicated
I'm talking about all of the lore in the
game I think it's dumb to say it's not
complicated
of course it is
[Applause]
I don't know about that Krusty
got your GB that's pretty cool there man
oh Witness
right fiction I mean there's so much to
try and understand that it's
overwhelming
jumped a little early on that one
foreign
I hate that attack I hate it
I really don't want to die to God
there we go
of all that is Charizard use
flamethrower one day
we'll return together
to our home what happened a lot with
Krusty
so cold
let's go
all right boys
I'm gonna pop this remembrance
and then I think we got a lot of spins
ahead of us
all right how many levels we got
please be good spins because this is so
important early game
this is so important early game bro
I will always be good with upgrading our
vigor
thank you all right spin one down spin
number two
[Applause]
hell yeah
okay
I feel like I'm getting somewhat lucky
right now
it's been number three
endurance I like it
spin number four
um
it's like it once our wants us to have a
good strength build
it's been five
Arcane we don't really want Arcane
anymore to be honest well yeah we do
yeah we do
faith
kind of a Mid Town of a mid
is this number six
it's been six
let's go whoa okay
I'm good with it a journal wouldn't
leave much room for player
interpretation in my opinion that kind
of makes the game that much more
interesting when you have to figure it
out
oh no I I don't want there to be like
answers given
to the to the lore at all no shot I
don't want that personally
okay
uh we got two more spins
the wheel wants a strength build
last spin yes
last spin
in faith again
okay
okay so we got two Vigor one endurance
three strength and two faith
interesting I like it
all right
we'll take it
not bad
you got gifted a membership Lord
you got gifted my man
from people's people just being nice
for a lord you were does he give runes
craving to the bones let's find out
go back you you wretched
yes sir Lord
hounds Fang I was just thinking that
I was just thinking about Bloodhounds
Fang
hmm
I'm back what I miss everything
I'm tempted to give some more
I mean how many more would you need for
the drunk stream
42. that's a lot
that's a lot of members
F that guy he steals your runes
I don't think there's anything wrong
with killing gostock every time you see
him I'd kill him at the main gate if I
didn't need him to open it
um I believe he did actually
yes he did Lord
I think strength faked but it's sort of
mid
I've heard good things about strength
fade
[Music]
okay we got one level let's do one spin
I'm just gonna do every time I feel like
it's possible to do a spin we're just
gonna do one
all right
spin it up let's go
also do you guys like the thumbnail or
do you think I could do like something
better
I thought it was kind of creative
hey it's like the thing we've had the
least of so
sick
we'll take it
you know
they're probably kind of a waste at this
point but
you know it's early game we can have
whatever okay
honestly uchigatana can take us so far
it's a good thumbnail
I thought so do you guys see how I put
it like
well I guess you can't see it anymore
but I put like the the wheel like in the
water but there was like a glow off of
it
I put effort in it
I'm not gonna kill him pops
thinking more fill in that particular
boss situation just reward
I was thinking more of fill in for that
particular boss's situation just as a
reward for someone like astel
was no in-game lore and is hard for
players to interpret their story
oh you meant like for a journal
well the hopefully they do that in
future DLC I don't think there should
ever be a journal
I mean isn't there
it's not called a lore book but isn't
there like a guide that came out
that tells a lot of the lore
Blasphemous played
we're still super early game we can't
like put our hand on anything yet
let's go get uh Bloodhounds Fang
also do I need to do blyde's no I don't
need to do his quest line we can find a
somber too somewhere else
I was trying to make a thumbnail with
the wheel as the wheel weapon holding
hole oh held by your character like this
and the wheels in his hand that's a good
idea too
I might change it to that because that's
honestly just a better idea you got all
the good ideas for tater
okay let's go get Bloodhounds Fang
and see if it's something we want to
pursue
why am I not remembering where it is
it's right here I didn't get anything
close
yes I did
Dark Moon Greatsword I mean not yet who
knows it could do like
you know all intelligence from here on
out and then we could
volume books in Japanese
I need to get one of those
I don't think I've ever rode this way
and I probably never will again
whatever ending we get Sater
whatever ending we get
Bloodhounds Fang plus blood flame blade
I use at the start of a speed run after
watching your video
go ahead and take that one
and go back over here
yay
all right
I think we definitely need way more like
dexterity to even use Bloodhound Spang
but it would be a major thing to have
later on
I mean that's one of the best weapons in
the game
get fried Daryl
gonna talk
17.
and what are we at 15 oh that's possible
we can definitely get that
we can definitely get that you could use
death poker I mean that's the best
weapon in the game or one of the best
I would I would literally say that it's
a GG
if we get that smoker
like good game because we won
okay where should we go now
is it even worth it at this point to go
to castlemore and to get like 3 800
runes from
from the Miss begotten it's literally
not
I don't think it's worth it that won't
even get us a level
we may not we just may not go south
at all the entire game
holy okay
uh gotta head to work have a great
stream Jake let's look at the wheel
thank you have a great day at work
imagine a wheel run an eldering item and
around oh my goodness
that could be fun to do someday
it's really not worth it
uh halberd's good
but we already have like a better weapon
we can definitely kill Ronaldo right we
don't have that much vigor
I'm trying to think of where to go next
there's one more flask upgrade in this
in the South and the church by The
Village
where's that again
I thought I already went down here
is there another upgrade over here
I'm gonna try to Astro
seal
we want to go for that and kill it
already
sore seal ductus Medallion halves
yeah that that's our course of action
we should literally do that you're right
we can also kill the dragon all right
let's kill the dragon and then we'll
head to get the dectus medallions
frenzied flame Village
is there a church over there
oh we should get our physic too
what's this
oh that's where you get on sheath
Mausoleum to dip the remembrance
that's a good idea too
okay I have to go back that way anyway
I'm trying to do it as efficiently as
possible
we're already two hours in and we're not
even close to done
not even close
where's the Dragon
there you are
foreign
[Music]
very long stream today Miro
foreign
foreign
after me with a dragon in its face
I think we already grabbed the seed
near castlemorne
actually I think we did
foreign
grab the gold pickled foul foot below
where Vari stands
oh because I have yeah
okay all right let's go back down here
it's the uh
yep we're going to the mausoleum Logan
thank you for the two bucks man I
appreciate you
we'll duplicate it uh
then we go over to castlemore okay your
remembrance for more runes more runes
more runes baby
more ruins more levels more spinny spins
and then we'll go to that Village I
don't remember their church over that
there was a church over there
I want to know this because I want to do
a video on all the churches
I think
I need to figure out where they all are
I guess I could look it up but
I believe you can duplicate it if you've
already used the uh
foreign
gotcha gotcha gotcha
I am speed okay
you guys remember when we tried to do a
speed run it took us eight hours and
four and a half of those hours were on
malakath
isn't that dumb
okay
let's go so where
sorry I'm blinking
stop the Lookouts
yeah you can always duplicate
I'll wait
okay oh [ __ ] that's what I needed the
foul foot for damn okay
three levels
wait let me put it on screen so you all
don't yell at me
one spin number one
mind this is a very interesting build
it's a very interesting build
why do you want me to get a lantern so
bad
I would say it's not important more mind
get more mind than vigor
we got one more yep
one more spinny spin
more strength
okay
okay
we've got nine points in the strength
today that's insane
okay
cool
confirm good stuff
good stuff good stuff
blyde built
it could be a blind build not gonna lie
you're not wrong
yeah that was that was okay go to Vari
down the beach at the end I I know what
you're talking about yeah
there's a lot of places to go right now
man my brain's all over the place okay
I'm going to this Village over here
first thing first
thing first
where the prosthesis is Aaron you guys
think I can just poop this [ __ ] out
still very early game
we just killed the Dragon
ah
foreign
DLC I hope time travel
you remember there was this
really a church over here
there is wow
is it named anything
what does that mean
well we got the flame of frenzy that's
good to have
glad we have it
oh the 80k runes the big one
ah
boring
okay
now
when I say that scared me
my heart dropped just now wow
Scarlet rot is a metaphor for AIDS
I mean okay you could say AIDS covid the
flu yeah it makes you sick yeah
I think we got that
okay let's go get the dactus medallions
now like we wanted to
forever ago
uh
baptismal church where you can go
to be baptized all right
can you see how many people watching art
members no
I don't even have a view count on ever I
have no idea how many people are here at
any point
I just read chat as it comes
don't look at me
oh don't tell me how Manny
I don't want to know
I have it off for a reason you foreheads
let me grab this just in case
I would treat you guys the same if there
were 10 000 people in the in the chat
room
that's why I keep it off
because I don't know if there's 10 000
people in the chat
and sometimes I'd call you stupid
just like I always do
I don't want to participate in a 10 000
chat room
okay
10 000 viewers does not equal 10 000
people chatting it equals more people
chatting
I I like don't know how to get more
viewers on YouTube live streams
because think about twitch
all you have to do on Twitch is be at
the top of your category right and then
you just automatically get more viewers
because you're at the top of the
category
but on YouTube nobody looks for streams
they just watch whatever Creator they
they watch right
I don't think it matters on your
subscriber count either
because honestly I had more viewers
streaming when the game first came out
and I had like 10 000 Subs
than I do now
oh imagine 10 000 people chatting at
once
I wouldn't be able to read it
I guess I can't jump down from here I
gotta go this way
what's ligma lick my balls
so many people watching and missing so
many likes
don't forget to like the stream guys go
ahead and like the stream right now if
you haven't already
I think that does help is anybody there
I'm not sure someone who might be
interested you can stream on both at the
same time I've been thinking of that
or I've been thinking of doing that
because I can like it's not against my
contract or anything
but uh
I don't know
I probably won't
but I do stream on Twitch sometimes I
just stream rocket league and listen to
music and that's it
there's usually like 12 people there or
something
what happened to Perry hotter we had to
do this we reached a milestone
so whenever we do this we'll go right
back to that unless we have to do
another special stream
you missed streaming did you used to
stream
spam barbaric Royer in his face
145.
145 but water break water break
you're a wizard Perry Auto
you are a wizard
am I a real boy
I'm lost
this way
Harry Potter's your main chick
uh Perry hotter's a dude
nothing wrong with that
so yes
you mean
just to have never know what's gonna
help us today
I'm a hot
um
get these nerds out of my way
should I make a thing where
I have like the text chat guy say like
every 30 minutes
to like the stream it'll just come out
of nowhere and be like make sure to like
the Stream
like the Stream
I guess we can do that
You're Gonna Learn spells and [ __ ]
and you're gonna be [ __ ] pleased
about it
every hour yeah
[Music]
how about every two minutes
every two minutes I'm like hey have you
guys heard of Amazon Amazon Prime no
have you guys heard of becoming a member
it makes you a cool kid at school
make sure to like the Stream
and become a member today to join our
Discord
we'll have all kinds of fun special
activities and if we get to 250 members
I'll do a drug stream where I'll look
like a complete dumbass in front of you
guys
see I I a lot of streamers do that and I
just don't want to
I can't do that personally
no shot
that standoff was kind of sick
be sure to check out raid Shadow Legends
it's such a fun game that I'm sure you
all will play if I tell you to right
oh yes well that's for subscribers
Joy has received millions of tummy rubs
through her life at this point
okay there's the first one now we gotta
go to Caleb
I just disliked the video
how could you
I bet you don't even dislike
it you just did it to do it
didn't you
all right oh I already did that
make sure to buy my Bitcoin guys it's
called
AGT
AGT suck my ass
coin
I don't know
hey I already did a nordvpn ad okay
that ad was fun
already done them
yeah [ __ ] coin very creative sorry that
that was not my most creative moment
foreign
I
don't want to deal with all that [ __ ]
over there you kidding me
that [ __ ] equals Death my guy
got a dragon
no thanks no thanks
thank you
so does she like legit eat tarnished
that's what it says in the name
I think we can level
okay
let's see wait let me do I have any
poppies
gotcha
perhaps she's from volcano Manor she
kind of looks like it is it isn't she
wearing like that Maiden Garb that kind
of tanith wears too
it's a good point
sorry about sorry but as a penster
gotcha
yeah she got you
it's a disguise hmm
he either eats tarnist or she
eats tarnished
right all right we got two levels
let's do it people
here we go
we need one more Dex to be able to use
Bloodhounds fan
we need one more
give it to me Daddy please
20 strength though
the wheel wants a strength build
that's what it wants
all right
let's keep it going let's keep it
rolling
well from the game the wife building
ogres Anastasia known to have eaten
countless tarnished while the skies as a
finger Maiden oh
that's from a description
damn
I wonder why she would do that
you use the golden Halbert now
wait I can
oh [ __ ]
we're gonna have to test this
is the golden halberd like really good
like full game
I don't know you're the lore Hunter well
you guys said quote from the game
I'm saying where
description of The Butchery knife gotcha
so she's a freak
got it
it's ogre for you
gotcha
azman's favorite weapon
I do love me some asthma gold
these Dino dogs are the scariest thing
in the game for me
I wasn't like writing a script for this
and I wasn't sure if I wanted to make a
video on it
I think Elden ring might be the best
horror game I've ever played
now if I made a title well if I made a
video titled
Eldon ring is the best horror game ever
made
do you think people would get mad about
that
or they'd be like true
they'll get mad they'll get furious
some people bro they would lose their
[ __ ] really
because it's not technically a horror
game I mean
guy I get more scared at Elden ring than
I did the Callisto protocol
I played like an hour equals protocol I
watched a lot of Callisto protocol which
is a horror game
like
I don't think a game has to be dark to
be a horror game
sorry Chad I'm like lost right now I'm
kind of an idiot okay here we go
but God of War is the best horror game
okay
it's a stretch
I mean have you guys seen how [ __ ]
creepy this game is have you ever paid
attention to it
you did you guys watch the video where I
taught where I showed you all a mass
genocide
of the Alvin oryx
in a village
you ever been to volcano Manor
you ever seen these crows around in
caled the dino dogs
the dancing women in The Windmill
Village
who rip your skin off to make clothes
the woman who has a power to Nuke an
entire continent and set it like
everything's poison now
the fact that someone tells you that you
literally get no [ __ ]
I think I can make a good argument for
it
but bro
I would probably not read the comments
uh the worm faces
in that place in the Altus Plateau that
place is terrifying
foreign
the Revenant like I think I can make a
really good argument
but I guess the horror Fanatics would go
crazy
yep the rates terrifying
I find the god skin to be scary too
we're like Godwin's face like what he's
become yeah you ever given a good long
look at that
it's terrifying
the grafted Scion
there's body horror psychological horror
blood pestilence I like that's what I'm
saying Taryn
I think this might be the scariest game
I've ever played and I've played a lot
of horror games
that are
made to be horror games and I find this
game to be creepier scarier
disturbing
so many ways
oh the sewers yeah like what goes on
down there [ __ ] insane
all right let's ride
we're doing a lot of setup right now
the bubble things at the Capitol I don't
know if I find those scary
but you guys are saying that the
audience of horror games
they would just say that I'm wrong
because Eldon ring is not considered a
horror game
I find that to be a terrible argument
the Sheep roll
[Music]
that's kind of creepy
they'd say you're wrong because Elden
ring isn't a horror that's not an
argument
such a bad argument
all the corpses and the mountaintops of
the Giants that's a good one too
Point yeah flame Peak
it's not traditional horde I don't think
it has to be considered traditional
horror to be a scary game
okay what if I titled it Elden ring is
the scariest game I've ever played
or Eldon ring is the scariest game
like I guess if I put the best horror
game
people would be like well
actually let me go ahead and make this
giant ass comment that I copy and pasted
from Reddit uh about my opinion on the
horror [ __ ] about Elden ring because
it's not really horror
in [ __ ] hell man
go for it that's an opinion true I I
don't want to rile people up man I
sometimes I get in the mood to rile
people up and sometimes I don't
okay we can get a lot of runes over here
who left the meeting place map
good question
it's on a dead guy
that spell goes hard
no
I want this one all right I'm already
poisoned [ __ ] it
we going
Alden ring has a few jump scares
I mean yeah it's some but I don't think
a game has to
to jump scare you to be considered a
horror game right
I like get annoyed at jump scares where
I'm just like oh yeah okay you're trying
too hard to scare me you know
damn it
there's different styles of horror it
seems more like an opinion than anything
on what people want to see us for
yeah
I agree with that
what's scary is that you get no maidens
that hurt
I already knew this man okay let me pop
all these
thanks for the two dollars potato
foreign
Chad can I talk to you about something a
little personal
or or can we do we ignore the parasocial
[ __ ]
we don't want to get parasocial up in
here
dude
every girl that I've talked to recently
where they ask me what do you do for a
living
and I say
I'm a YouTuber
and they go
so you're unemployed
and I'm like
come on
like
every girl
says that
I'm like really
you not know what YouTube is
and then like okay so a lot of them will
go like oh YouTube what kind of videos
do you make Are you a vlogger
and I go
as soon as they say are you a vlogger
then I'm like I know what side of
YouTube they're on and they don't know
nothing about games
so I say
no I make videos about gaming
and I just see them shut down
they just go
and I'm like
dude all the girls around me here at
least all the girls I've talked to so
far
they don't know anything about video
games and it's sad
okay we can level one time I'm doing a
spinny spin
but I thought like I don't know
like man bro
it's about to get toxic
a little bit more Health always helps
big
are they also a tick tocker I mean maybe
that's what I should say like
should I should I because I have 230 000
followers on tick tock and I don't even
post tick tocks anymore
um should I tell them that and they'll
be like oh my God
like even I thought YouTube would be
better than than Tick Tock but maybe not
you should date Instagram models do you
think I can pull an Instagram model
I am pretty cute
just say you make content I almost want
to say I work for Google
[Laughter]
right
I work for Google
oh that's cool
there's so few that will understand it
no I know I've faced it I'm old enough
now but it's it's so weird I feel like I
would find some
girl gamer out there who who likes me I
guess
that'd be nice
foreign
I'll be your sugar tarnished
why do you say it like that
I'll be your sugar tarnished
Logan thank you for the five man you
I'll do whatever you want Daddy what
okay sorry
I'm searching I'm a searching employee I
work for Google maybe you are
considering model like a professional
model but there are many that just post
pics and consider themselves models
I mean
maybe I should stop doing the the normal
dating right like maybe I gotta start
dming or is that weird
is it like weird to DM girls on
Instagram
I don't I don't know how I've never
really done that ever
be like hey what's up
I have no idea
but I've always just done like dating
apps in my area and like every girl that
I've talked to
they just don't like gaming
I gotta find someone who likes gaming
I have to
well I say I say Instagram
[Music]
because
they'd probably understand what I do
what do you think
wrong side of the head
that fire came out so fast
I don't think I can kill him yet
I need to go like upgrade my Uchi
uh
kind of cringe yeah go somewhere with
girls and games where's that
well my father used to say to me if you
wanted different results do different
process
yeah
man on Instagram they hit me up
some have fake pics of porn stars though
that'd be kind of weird minute I say I
play video games I get asked if it's
Animal Crossing or Sims apparently
that's all we play
there's nothing wrong with that I don't
think there's anything wrong with the
girl only playing like the switch
playing Pokemon or or Animal Crossing or
whatever that's fine but at least they
know about gaming and they won't
immediately feel like I'm unemployed
because I don't have like a traditional
job you know what I mean
so so weird
you know what I should say
I've heard this from Tim the tap man
this is what he says
I'm an online male entertainer
there's a lot of different things you
can think about that one
I'm an online male entertainer
and they go
huh
[Laughter]
oh talk about another creepy thing in
the game
you tell me that I didn't creep you out
first time you heard this what running
by
Eldon Rings a horror game bro I'll say
it
only fans win exactly exactly
I'm a long form tick tocker
you know you can post up to 10 minutes
on Tick Tock now
no one ever does but you can
this discussion makes me sad I'm just
saying in my experience limey I know
there's plenty I just have not met the
right girl you know what I mean I
haven't met the right one and I'm
finding it like I'm almost 28. it's like
when am I gonna find the right one man
this is taking a while
you know I've seen a lot of my buddies
are married
for years I'm like I haven't even I
haven't been on a good date in a while
you know like God damn
didn't creep you out creep me out
Alden ring is scary horror game
maybe that's how we get a bunch of new
viewers they come in to yell at me that
it's not a horror game
[Music]
I sat down and listened it was beautiful
I did too but I was creeped out
yeah
I I mean I haven't dated anybody long
term I mean okay so I've been in
I've been in two serious relationships
in my life my first relationship I was
in I was in that relationship for six
years between the time I was 17 and 23.
which is a terrible time to break up
with a long-term girlfriend when you're
23 years old which is like when you
think you'd be getting married
some maybe you know
uh and then I didn't date for
well you know I won't say all the you
know Andre thing but I didn't seriously
date anybody else for a few more years
and then I dated this one girl for six
months
uh she turned out to be batshit insane
so
and like she was literally diagnosis I
not batshit insane she was bipolar she
had to stop smoking weed for her job and
that literally changed her entire
personality
um
I see it as dodging a bullet but I still
dated her for like
eight months I think
no not all women are crazy that's not
what I'm saying
but she uh
very high maintenance
so
yep
very very high maintenance
which is not not for me
a lot of dudes out there are [ __ ]
nuts too
hope women are not crazy dude we just
think they're crazy
women think we're crazy
as well
well I presume
oh I am can I get anything from here
perhaps no I need runes
okay
we need to go
to the academy did I grab the damn key
I didn't did I
nice save I didn't say any of this
women are not crazy saying all women are
crazy is dumb
however the last girl I seriously dated
wound up being crazy
but I'm not saying all women are crazy
make chaos take the world there we go
uh
excuse me
look at the state of Fam I'm not nope
stop stop nope
stop it
we are not going that deep
feminism manism no no no
stop it right now
okay
okay
all right
what are these stats looking like
kind of weird
mostly strength and decks
gotten some good attributes in in a lot
of things it's actually hasn't been that
bad this could have gone real bad
all women is definitely generalizing a
hundred percent though it's pretty
common these days for girls to try
marrying guys just to divorce them and
collect no no did my game crash
what
why the rush
I'm I'm not in any rush I'm at a point
now where it's like all right I'm just
gonna let the right one come to me
I think my game crashed
we don't have to respin we'll respawn
right there
the conversation topic crashed the game
yeah
yeah I guess it crashed my game very
rarely crashes
very very rarely crashes yep close the
program damn bro
damn bro
the game bonked itself out of commission
dude
I was dumped a few days ago and honestly
I'm done trying for some time it's kind
of how it works man I'm sorry that
happened but
you know it is what it is
you'll be okay
just focus on yourself
uh it's because of
oh my god dude no I I even said like do
I get parasocial with you guys should I
even bring this up all I was asking was
how come I can't meet a girl who
understands my job respects my job and
at least is okay with video games
toxic
I'm so toxic
guy in the world
I want a girl who wants to play Pokemon
while I stream
you know it would be the cutest thing
look look at my setup right here look at
this
look at that big TV that she could she
could be sitting right here
I got a PS5 and Xbox X hitting there
he could set up the switch play Pokemon
on that big ass TV
yes I like the Cowboys
maybe another YouTuber
I mean that'd be interesting
but I haven't met
someone like that
I played neo2 bloodborne Monster Hunter
see there you go
yeah I just want to be loved
that's all
I just want to be loved
by someone who doesn't like not respect
what I do
so I will say like a lot of these dates
they they truly just don't understand
what I do but that doesn't mean that
they they don't want to keep like it's a
they immediately don't want to talk to
me anymore I just get that vibe from
them right away that they're like oh I
don't know what that is and I find that
kind of weird
but I had one date that was like so
you're unemployed I was like what
wow okay
it's like no I have you know
at the time I was like I have almost 100
000 subscribers and she's like don't
people on Tick Tock have like millions
of of followers I'm like
I I just knew right then and there that
she was not the one
it's like oh no
also there's a big difference between
followers on Tick Tock and subscribers
on YouTube
he told me that I got two lost in video
games but it's what I like doing I never
judge her for her Hobbies you're not the
right one then man it's okay
I think I might just start saying I work
for Google
and male entertainer for Google
let's see how that goes next time
I'm cute thank you
seen people really not respect gaming or
even anime like how dare you enjoy
something that's not watched like the
office for the yeah right I love the
office by the way but like God damn
how do you stand oh God
stop
you love who you love
you love who you love that's how I feel
I don't even told you guys I practice
Buddhism though dude we gotta stop
guys the the spinny spins
come on guys
he spins
it's so much fun I just got baited so
[ __ ] hard
it's not a baited question of course I
do but
man
I I always wonder like I wonder why
people care
let people love who they love
and I'll do the same
oh thanks Dragon I'm glad you like it
really [ __ ]
uh you're a Chad Jake not a giga Chad
but like a micro chat at least
I'm not a giga
they care in case they're wrong all
right
foreign
I would remind you to push memberships
but everyone here already has one
uh yep hey guys become a member if
you're not a member become a member do
it right now
if we get to 250 members I'll do a drunk
stream
and that'll be a good time
so we got a giga Giga Chad that really
tall lady and her dog in Hogwarts or
what I think that's where we're going
next yeah
I just wanted to open this up
[Music]
I don't I'm poor
[Music]
what's your favorite from game
tween Elden ring and bloodborne
together
no maidens how about some members right
exactly
[Applause]
there it is guys let's go Logan
thank you for the two dollar Super Chat
and then just gifts 10 members
let's go baby thank you man
I appreciate you very much dude thank
you thank you
it's gonna say who every single one
Astra got one Astro's been here all day
so that's a big one
agent got one good good good good
good
but thank you Logan I don't know why you
gift so many members but I I appreciate
it
I really do thank you thank you
I think those are gonna pull out pretty
late
I don't know YouTube has got to fix
their gifted member thing because it
it's really glitchy
see how it comes up like that
I think it has to find people
foreign
who needs women when he got Logan
Brew
hello I mean I would like someone to
love me I would
favorite remembrance boss I think it'll
always be redone I [ __ ] love radon
uh Kennedy thank you for the for the
membership man welcome to the tarnish
appreciate it bro
thoughts on putting a sub counter on
stream
I mean we hit 100K do we really need it
we could
I don't know is it something you want
we're past the threshold
we hit the daily member goal let's go
good [ __ ] we still gotta hit this one
but we hit the daily thing so that's a
good start thank you
where's my gift
all I've learned is that you have to
you have to talk a lot in the chat and
be and you have to participate and then
you have a greater chance of getting
gifted a membership when somebody gifts
members
yep we hit our goal two days in a row
and I upped it by 25.
because yesterday's goal was 25.
today I was like I'm gonna up at the 50
see what happens and we hit it because
you guys are crazy
I appreciate it guys
thank you thank you
thank you
how goes the wheel of leveling it's
going pretty good
I would like more Vigor but we're here
we're kind of just doing a lot of setup
right now
we're kind of progressing through the
game
I had to enable myself to be able to
accept gifts
yeah I wonder why that's a thing
good good point uh
good point some
good point
uh bungalist thanks for gifting one
member I appreciate that thank you thank
you
what up pock Ute is at 2 14 almost three
times the number you had on Monday right
I don't know what happened Javen you
guys just really like incentives
we're gonna have to talk about this
drunk stream if we hit it
you missed Alexander
you mean corn
YouTube members is very new
uh compared to Twitch
okay I think I have the full now I want
to go get the other
golden seeds over here
Jesus
Tim with the five gifted you guys are
going crazy
Tim thank you man
also paying it forward you guys don't
have to do that but I really appreciate
it thank you
[Music]
it's still in beta it's definitely still
in beta
but it works
I really I appreciate it a lot guys
thank you
you're gonna drink during the drunk
stream good
Peru
I don't know what happens Peter I was
trying to research how memberships work
I think it does give to random
subscribers whenever we go over the
threshold of how many people are in the
chat
twitch
if we get 250 members C3 we'll do a
drunk stream
foreign
we'll have to talk about that Javen
I was gonna say like maybe we do a shot
every time I die
that could be real bad
maybe you guys will let me hit a
threshold and then we can't go past it
you know what I mean like okay Jake you
can only take 12 shots once you get past
that like we gotta stop you know
foreign
I'm a whiskey guy
I like whiskey soda
all right
I shot every three deaths
maybe yeah maybe we upped the threshold
once we reach like Malachi's millennium
if we do because I'm drunk
okay guys
uh
[ __ ] your flame of ambition [ __ ]
but thank you again I'm gonna keep
saying thank you because I I really do
appreciate it
gifted members mean a lot
um
because I like
I don't know if you guys know this but I
streamed on Twitch for four years
um I did incentives on Twitch for Rocket
league and Rocket League coaching
that people were really into and so a
membership is equivalent to a subscriber
on Twitch if you don't know
um the highest amount of memberships or
Subs on Twitch that I had
was 2500.
and that was [ __ ] crazy
I think we did that in like six months
we got to 25 so it would be like having
2500 members here
that was like Bonkers like I couldn't
believe it
so I'm not saying we ever get to that
because
I don't know how YouTube will do that
but
this is a good start
Winchester thanks for becoming a great
room I appreciate you dude welcome
welcome and also if you got a membership
or just became a member make sure to
join our members only Discord it's
linked in the description or it's not in
the description you gotta
you got to go to the community Tab and
you'll see a link there this community
tab on this channel you'll see a link go
join it
a lot of new people join it so
good be fun
should be fun oh definitely T free
[Music]
a shot before a boss
we'll figure it out we gotta get there
first
[Music]
I'm glad Javen I'm glad you like it here
man
so all I want is for people to like what
I make
two shots per boss Max yeah we'll have
to make a Max for sure for sure
we got you bail
at least that works I'm happy about that
okay
where should we go
I think we gotta kill Ronaldo and then
we should kill radon
[Music]
that's what we're doing
but I've set it up to where we can get
these places really quick
oh I should also see if I can upgrade
can't yet
I think we'll be okay
now I don't want to do Ronnie's Quest
it takes so long
not that long
one shot for every death in one of the
hero's Graves no thank you
God
I mean check again Astro it should be
right there if you scroll down
no no no no no no
there was somebody a few weeks ago that
couldn't find it because
they had a really old device they were
on so it might depend on the the device
you're on where the community tab just
glitches out
is there a membership tag in the
community tab or there's like a literal
membership tag
hubba
I'm glad you like advance
mobile doesn't allow Community tab
I think it's iPads something like that
what is wrong with you
what
we talking about Paul
welcome Christian
welcome welcome welcome
that mist kind of hurt my soul
Community tab on mobile
yeah
wish everything wasn't so finicky
YouTube's got a lot of stuff to iron out
but they're getting better
they're trying
oh okay yeah the tray
you got [ __ ] bro
all right
let's get it doggy
foreign
foreign
GG
uh
I think that was just coming in late
but thanks again to Tim and um
and our boys
holy [ __ ] and Logan
dude I can't be getting tired
can't
can't bro
all the homies okay
that's decent runes right 14k
yeah all right all right
my name is Tim you're welcome
thank you for that
we'll see how many levels we can hit
one
let's run it
let's run it baby
I'm not getting tired
I'm good
I mean we got enough strength video game
[Applause]
okay okay we'll take it we'll take it
all right you know strength
it's what we're rocking it's what we're
rolling you know
it's what we're rocking and what we're
rolling
what's Jake's last name
who's trying to stalk me
who's trying to stalk me huh
strength big
we can definitely beat Ronaldo right
hold on let me get let me get my [ __ ]
together over here
nobody I swear okay
a video game girlfriend
um interesting
okay uh let me get my physics
enhances charged attacks that'll be good
negates damage in the mix physic let's
do that
and then
let's get
two of these we should be okay
what do you what do you guys think my
last name is
I'm not gonna tell you but if anyone can
guess it I will give you seven million
dollars
that I don't have
and I'm also kidding if you know it
don't say it [ __ ] you
Reagan
um
it's agent
Michael Freud
Jake The Snake I like that
Bagel booty Morris there's absolutely no
way anyone could possibly guess it
unless you somehow figured it out
it's not a guessable last name
it's not
oh you lived
no Trey
actually do I care I don't think I do
nah don't say it
um
Jefferson
Engelbert
dick hmm
nope
it is a super uncommon last name
super uncommon
not Italian
from State Farm that's a good guess
very good guess
Jake Beanstalk you weren't supposed to
tell them Trey
my last name is Beanstalk
weird
mcjackleberg
good guess
why that kid going after my toes bro
[Music]
not Jewish
what is my last name
I think it's German
it is German
hush
little cover
I have a neighbor neighbor whose last
name is Gaylord for real soon birthday a
new
Sweeting fresh and pure Jake Good
Neighbor
it's not Washington
Jaeger
foreign
[Music]
Oppenheimer like the new movie
dinkleberg
[Music]
there we go
right it starts with an s
s
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
s
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope
squeeze
you guys are bad at this I don't know
how you could ever be good at it
yes it will Gabe yes it will
I will hold things
Miss Cube getting weird
starter
that sounded close
my
neck Nitzel
I don't know of anyone else besides my
family who has this last name
I'll just say it
send word far and why I don't really
care I don't have anything to hide
you guys ready for the last queen of
Korea
granola of the full moon
storks
and the Majesty of the night she
conjureth yeah laugh it up hell no one
it's not a big deal Trey
tell no one
foreign
[Music]
no my IP
come oh
no the camera no no oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
I just got completely [ __ ] by the
camera
that hurt my soul
that is not a German word I was told our
last name is German
storks
artist enemy in the game is a [ __ ]
camera
this is the IRS I'm gonna need you to
send me 10 Walmart gift cards
uh it's the only long run back too
distorts
it's a really weird last name that I
don't really like but it's mine
yep last name placidusacks
plastic Deuce ax
all right let's go beat up all these
kids again
shorts
where is this kid oh
come on
damn it
[Music]
my Vigor is so low it's insane
for this area
[Music]
[Music]
it's not spelled like that GB
well that's not good
what ammo truth
all the secrets
come on
he's getting all spammy
[Music]
come on
God that attack is annoying
I am the blade of Michelob
it was me the entire time chat
dude the dragon's firing this game
reaches so far
oh double
[Applause]
oh
my fate life under my move
[Music]
did y'all see her literally disappear
so after she does that
he disappears
RJ thanks for becoming an oven Lord
that's big thank you man I appreciate
that
did you see her disappear rewind I can't
rewind
but I have never seen that
he does that all right I mean if she
does that I've literally never [ __ ]
seen that before I've also never dodged
through her summon without getting not
knocked back either
wow
she just that was a weird wow all right
okay
I had no idea if she could do that
or Phoenix
my sword went right through her too man
well
she only disappears with the troll so if
she summoned the dragon or the dogs I
would have won
interesting
bear shitness
save that for a second phase
yeah yeah sleep tight bound tight by
your mother's
[ __ ]
[Music]
sometimes that comes out fast and
sometimes it lingers for a long time
time to time to be born
[Music]
first glitch I've seen on that too
[Music]
oh that book was right in my mouth what
wait what
hey Kirby
all right interesting
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
didn't even get the summon that time
[Music]
that's big boys
I completely deleted her that time
bye Felicia
um
I went two days ago that Mr Poopy
butthole can be a spirit Ash my sweet
what come out what
seeing Oliver and beam miss you true
okay
all right how many levels we got
let's do it
here we go
these are some big important spinny
spins chat let's see what we get
that right there is bloodhound's Fang
we can use bloodhound's Fang now spin
number two
that's Big W
age
Faith
kind of mid
however we can use the golden hall bird
if we want to that's good
spin number three
decks again I think yep decks again okay
good good
been number four been number four
faith is becoming more prominent in the
build it is it is becoming prominent it
is okay spin number five
oh come on
good endurance is Big endurance is big
for us
last one
hey Kirby welcome back bro good to have
you in the tarnish dude thank you thank
you bro
oh
oh
those were some good spins
I thought that was gonna go to mine and
I was gonna be like Oh no you're on on
[Music]
oh man okay that was that was some good
spins chat that was really good W spins
right there big time
all right now do we want to use
Bloodhounds fangs
I think we do not
come out say I
can't use the golden Hall Burger anymore
well yeah to be better
I think we want to use this
we were using Uchi yes
okay let's see what we can do about
upgrades
because we're definitely gonna we will
annihilate radon
uh with this
and good answer
okay still rolling yeah those are the
channel find them well a green GB agreed
so we need a one but well let's see what
we have
we don't have any sombers at all
okay
where can I get a somber one I'm
blanking on it in my brain
I don't want to buy them from the EG
could
okay
it's kind of this kind of mid it's kind
of mid kind of mid kind of mid we'll
take it though
we can easily find sombers everywhere
well then I presume
is the moon an outer God please my
children are starving
this is a lot of money
it's a lot of runes
it's the fastest way to get them
I can go to any of the lorenia caves
Ryan lucaria
no I haven't Kirby
run through the yeah we should go
through that tunnel
before I buy anything we want to go
right here
bow
my nizzle
was that was that bad
did you guys like the for Sizzle nizzle
or should I never say that again
we're going to the tunnel
it's going good Mike we're making decent
progress
probably not all right
I thought it was kind of fun
you don't mind it
no cap on a stack
Willis Willa
you don't mind it
no cap on a stack
I'll have to look into that Kirby that
sounds cool
I think I'm on the wrong side
oh what the [ __ ]
okay I'm going over here I'm I'm lost in
the sauces right now
Jake's an agent but he is not free
oh I'm not easy chat also I feel like a
big reason that I haven't been like
I've
like that I haven't found the right girl
yet
I am very picky
very
so it's it's mostly my fault probably
like if if my
if my standards not my standards
these standards weren't so high
then
I'd probably be with a girl at this
point but
I'm very picky like I I won't date a
girl just because they're like there you
know
castlemorne are there smithing Stones
there
sombers
cut up
I like
oh [ __ ]
shut your mouth yeah
no I'm not saying hit and quit I'm just
like you know
like I'm sure if I wasn't so picky
or
whatever
if my standards weren't so high then
I'm sure I could settle with someone you
know
but
so I'd say it's mostly my fault
no no I'm never gonna settle I just
can't
personality or looks
um
both
both
[Music]
[Music]
there we go I have no summers at all GB
I don't know how this happened
everyone's got someone out there
I agree
I will say I wasn't putting myself out
there very much
like
the last few years
to be totally honest did I [ __ ] myself
I mean probably
oh no there we go
okay
okay
everyone needs to shut up and get
married
I gotta find the right one
yeah the club will be better here you're
right
because of all these doofies
blood ounce Fame will just Bonk off
these guys
never want to marry dude I want to get
married that sounds fun to spend like
the rest of your life with like your
best friend that sounds great
it sounds poggers
I guess you don't have to get married if
you don't want to
these delayed ass [ __ ]
wait can I get the somber
um Bell
from the boss at the bottom here
less hassled than not getting married
in some ways yeah
we did
oh
my God
I forgot where I came from
going down is probably the right call
you're crazy man
I don't think it was that that deep for
that guy but there he was trying to kill
me
foreign
marriage is a title it's way more than a
title
you're vowing to somebody to be with
them forever
that's a really big deal
made a video about Melina mentioning
that she wants to haunt you because she
embraced chaos I mean kinda he's a he's
a glomide queen
okay I got the somber one but I'm dead
I was completely stuck on that guy
I like couldn't move at all
that's before divorce yeah
see that's probably the scariest part
um of marriage is like well
What If eventually you don't like each
other and you can't figure it out and
then you get divorced
divorce has to be the worst [ __ ]
thing the worst experience
one of the worst experiences ever
especially if you have kids
by that point you know
did I not do that oh this was the
elevator that's right that's why I
called that up
I was asking to check it before telling
any theories about it
what
um
I mean my parents are never getting
divorced definitely
um they've been together my 30 plus
years
they love each other
um but my mom's parents got divorced and
that affected her a lot she said
I
see look we we got a lot of the sombers
that we needed Chet just by going in
here instead of buying it all that's big
big
your parents didn't last 10 years
yeah I mean how many what's the
percentage of marriages that end in
divorce
foreign
there we go
foreign
you really can just bully these things
with a blunt weapon
good stuff chat
we're about to go ham
like pretty quick here
we're about to go crazy I think almost
done
all right
like once once we get this Bloodhounds
Fang going I think we can beat like
anything although our our level is
pretty low still so that'll still be
hard but having a really good weapon
get up stop praying help me
okay
hold on Spang Bang Bang
still need a four
we could go buy the four
I don't know where to get a four
where is a four isn't there one in the
in uh the academy
there's a four
uh
five six seven are in volcano Manor
I'll just go to EG
[ __ ] your parents Smith [ __ ] fifty
percent our grandparents were willing to
work on [ __ ] and put up with [ __ ] there
too
but that we are too weak to deal with a
relationship we're too selfish and too
narcissistic I think selfishness has
really become a thing in these newer
Generations yeah
braved just spend the runes
okay something
so we need a five
six and seven are in volcano Manor
yeah
five six and seven are in volcano Manor
uh
uh I know where to get an eight and a
nine and then tens late
all right
okay
I'm thinking
yep yep yep Mira yep
yeah five six and seven are in volcano
Manor so should we go there
we should kill radon right let's go kill
radon
let's go [ __ ] him up
sorry
volcano Manor is [ __ ]
I love volcano Manor Loki
what is your head here nothing it's my
face
all the enemies
uh yeah
yeah it felt like Florida this morning
Trey
like a like a morning
in Florida
the YouTuber Kirby yeah
to the festival I guess we can kill this
Dragon too yeah
I mean let me hit this real quick
Garden of eyes the mod I mean I think
that was made by the YouTuber named
Garden of ice
I think
I don't know if we're killing this thing
guys
foreign
go ahead and leave
how was that Dragon harder than radon
there's an enemy called Garden of Oz
cool
okay
definite tactile Retreat there
that could have been real bad real quick
yeah bleed would help but yeah
I definitely definitely guess we're done
excuse me doggos
somber 6 is also in this in the wells
yeah I think our best bet is to get it
in volcano Manor though don't you think
no idea what that is Mike
can't wait till Elder ring modding scene
gets as big as other from games
is it not big
then you got to start Ronnie Quest no
all you have to do is get delay and Dell
and then this unlocks
favorite side of Grace
your mom's
never mind
guys look at my [ __ ] health bar
it's dumb
favorite boss this one
real mature
[Music]
we're watching it
before we begin allow me to paint you
the full picture
[Music]
your mom's bed chamber
General Rodan is cursed ever to wander
outside by Melania Scarlet wrought his
wits are long gone
guys is it Leonard or Leonard
now he gathers the corpse as a former
friend who holds alike gorging on them
like a dog
foreign
at the sky
but now
we must make Merry oh Gathering of
Champions the rebels begin why is it
Leonard it doesn't even make sense
Leonard
I said that in my radon video nine
months ago where I said Leonard in all
of the Comets are like bro what the [ __ ]
is Leonard I'm like I feel like I've
heard that in every Knights and armor
movie I've ever seen like every medieval
movie ever I hear Leonard
makes so much more sense than Leonard
what is he a [ __ ] accountant
it could be Leonard I don't
I don't respect the oh
the [ __ ] is a letter
what the [ __ ] is a kilometer
[Music]
foreign
I die after one hit chat
no and he got knocked down
ah
okay this might take a few tries
my Vigor is so low
it's so low man
oh wait you can't a bigger check
okay
this is more of a don't get hit check
just don't get hit
that one's patches so [ __ ] him well
patches is dead so no it's not
it's usually patches
I'm gonna go right
dude really how do you dodge that one
okay that was just a bad attempt
oh that that was as bad that that was
just not good I was like yeah let me sit
in front of them
that'll go well
let me just sit in front of them and see
what happens and he [ __ ] hit me what
kind of crazy man is that
he's not supposed to do that
yeah I don't run away
foreign
[Music]
oh wow
solid start
where'd he go
oh
foreign
phase two that's good
he's almost dead
run
run
nice zero Rune pickup
foreign
oh [ __ ]
stop it
oh no
okay
he's doing the thing I'm running away
holy [ __ ]
not me not me not me
go go go go go go go go
one
wow
let's go
I got a snap
first try
that was three tries the first true two
were pretty bad
pretty bad Trice
that fight's really intense when you
have no health
why do I hear myself oh there we go
foreign
[Music]
we're gonna have to spin it
of course
70
000 Rooney boys
Plus
this
oh
110k
holy talities
all right
a lot of spins
we need Vigor badly
we need it
true Miro true all right
you guys ready
let's see how many we can get
eight levels
let's go
I'll never be mad with endurance I will
never be mad about endurance ever
it's a good spin spin number two
[Applause]
is that okay because we have blow Downs
Fang no it doesn't scale with that [ __ ]
kind of a waste
we go again
[Applause]
don't don't do this [ __ ] to me
don't do this with me bro
okay
okay
that upped our damage a bit
might have to go to another weapon
[Applause]
give me some hell please
oh my God okay I mean that's not awful
but [ __ ]
[Applause]
we've leveled Vigor six times
foreign
[Applause]
one in endurance one in strength one
index
three in faith
and two in Arcane
okay
okay
I don't think we can use this weapon
okay did you see our new emote
it's me staring directly into the camera
sounds like a you problem
okay
okay
is the golden halberd good because I
don't think so
uh
God Slayer Greatsword
can I
this is gonna be [ __ ] rough chat can
I beat the Apostle in radon's Tower
let's go find out
that Apostle is harder than radon
no I didn't get the sword seal yet let's
go do that
wait no I didn't get it
I didn't get it I went and got The
Medallion that's right
it drops 94 000. are you guys cool with
me killing this dragon
to get runes
your idea potato is really forming here
of course okay that might take a while
this is exactly what I was hoping for
love this this is going like honestly
the start was going really well and now
it's not going very well
I don't think I can beat that Apostle
either GB
Pam just making sure you guys are cool
with it because you know some people
literally think it's cheating
they do
that's a big rune
you know what else is cheating
that
[Laughter]
I'm not dying in there today
part of the game part of the game part
of the game
laughs
and thank you potato for the two dollar
Super Chat I appreciate it man
that's cheating
[Music]
if it's cheating why didn't Miyazaki
patch it you can't patch a guy leaving
the game
foreign
I don't think
where do you hit him
I don't really do this
on his armpit no no shot
oh up here
wait
the tail
really
[Music]
like here
oh
there we go
so chat uh
how's it going
Benny benion been on any fun dates
lately
13 000 damage right there
oh do I have a golden foot I feel like I
do
temporarily boost items I don't have the
golden foot
that's okay
can you speed this up I'm doing my best
could we go cheese the uh
the Black Knight
as well
or one of the calvary dudes
because we did that so fast before
night's gallery
why is this Dragon here are we really
just meant to like run away from this
guy and never talk to him again
oops
you went to the Opera I've never been to
the Opera how's that
did you like it
we get 13k damage we're we're fine it
just takes off
can this Dragon do anything when you
kill all the little baby dragons
have a good one massive thanks for being
here man
it dies oh
is this help with bleed
probably not
foreign
Health pool huh
okay trip
ah
thank you
die
there we go
rest my sweet prince okay
just kill him okay you're so slow
I'm sorry
all right back to the wheel
four more levels
and then I gotta go get a drink and go
pee all right
you guys ready
four more spinny spins
bigger please be bigger
oh my God
why is it rigged against
good
that's not the worst
not the best either neither is that
this [ __ ]
give me 18 Vigor please dude
it's not even close man
[Applause]
dude
I mean that's okay ish but [ __ ] man
we are the
we are the weakest strength build ever
L spins
all right
God damn bro
all right we're going here
I'm gonna go get a drink real quick to
give me more caffeine and more energy
um and then I'm gonna go pee and then uh
we'll be back and we're gonna go to
volcano Manor that's our next step
hi metal I love you okay bye
foreign
foreign
foreign
y'all don't think I'm watching I'm
always watching
hit a hemorrhoid
let's talk about Jake behind his back
also I didn't poo I peed
I hope you wash your hands why would I
do that
I have a clean dick
thank you metal I appreciate that
proof
okay volcano Manor how do we get there
uh I mean we have access
we can literally go there
um
do we want to go up this way
yes
virgin
do you oh right do we want to go through
that like the secret way or do we want
to go we can we can just walk there
because if we go the secret way then we
have to beat the noble which I don't
know if we can do
so let's just go this way
should we go to creepy Village first
maybe we can be that apostle
Let's test it out
Let's test it
yeah everybody like the stream it helps
get more people in the Stream
so like the stream if you haven't
already
I think that's the only way to get more
viewers is to have more likes on a
stream I'm not even kidding
at least on YouTube for now
Altus and mount glimmer around the same
level okay so if we can beat this guy
then we can be
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's get it
I don't want to talk about it
[Music]
good damage
foreign
bad attempt bad attempt
right
they always have
yeah
and Exorcist
I literally just got bigger checked
and there's nothing I can do about that
[Music]
no
should I use torrent Maybe
I'm not very good on torrent to be
honest
let's hope the second time goes better
same attack yeah
foreign
[Music]
I just got saved by the hill
I don't like torrent for this
because you just get staggered so easy
I know that I know the move set I can
beat him I just gotta not [ __ ] up
basically
this gives us decent runes too right
[Music]
I just can't get hit
[Music]
foreign
good thing I had that
this fight in this setting is so cool
[Music]
ah that was really good
damn it
he caught me bro
yeah yeah I died
I went for the follow-up man and that I
guess he
keeps going
stuck up on poison arrows
I'm not a big Arrow guy
sorry
okay at least we're right here
dungeon godskin
dungeon
[ __ ] man
foreign
that attack has got my number huh
jeez
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Tower right
oh why do you have so many attacks
[Music]
foreign
I can beat him
yeah it was crotch
because so many moves and they're so
hard to read
foreign
that attack and I won't get hit and he
did it
[Music]
[ __ ] delays dude
jump [ __ ] you
that attack's good
foreign
he like caught me in it what the [ __ ]
I rolled backwards and I was in the
attack and Dot like rolled a weird way
man
we should level Vigor huh
that'd be really great
foreign
[Music]
I feel like I can't do The Bloodhounds
finesse
he just like
he just follows it up perfectly
maybe I should just do normal attacks
and it'll be easier
his eye gets
all right bro look at how many times
it's attacking right there
uh it feels bad that I got so close and
died because now like all the next
attempts are gonna be bad
no we tried on the horse I don't like it
I'm on the horse
have a good one fiction
few charged Heavies do not break his
voice
and I wait for very specific moments to
do that attack
I thought it was underneath them
[Music]
foreign
God damn
jeez dude
[Music]
foreign
at you immediately
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it comes out so fast I don't really know
what to do about that one
peace dude
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's [ __ ] annoying
[Music]
God damn it
[Music]
foreign
dude that attack is so fast I can't do
anything about it
I don't even know if this is worth it
now it's like out of principle
oh
it's a [ __ ] guy man
foreign
did I get to believe that entire fight
[Music]
the [ __ ] was that when do you do that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I actually dodged it that time
[Music]
that's so early
[Music]
get [ __ ] [ __ ]
foreign
I think I've died to that attack every
time it's just that one
God bro
makes me mad that I can't just beat him
like this because I clearly can
I died of the same attack
it comes out so quick that sometimes I
do not have the stamina to dodge it
I try to get on torrent
nope
more light attacks I think I might have
a better time with the Uchi
then The Bloodhounds Fang
but I have to hit him more to get the
bleed proc
I have to hit them more in a row like I
can't wait too long
[Music]
that's a good start and I didn't have
the [ __ ] stamina to roll again
foreign
[Music]
I got my bleed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
why did I get hit that time because I
was in front of them
I literally just stood in the middle and
didn't get hit I guess I was in the
wrong spot in the middle
[ __ ]
that irritates the [ __ ] out of me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I almost got [ __ ] by the game right
there with the camera
[Music]
there it is
night that man that was not worth it at
all why did we do that
why we do that
I got as many runes popping right there
crazy all right well it was cool we want
we just wanted to listen to the music
right
one level guys let's see what we get
foreign
okay skill issue is funny
oh man
I was thinking I could put this stream
on the second Channel
we do any normal upload is gonna be a
lore video or something like that
or do you think this channel would like
a cut down of this stream
Maybe
I guess it's still Elden ring so I could
I would love to edit down my streams and
post those as videos but
um
blooper vid
get Hella views
do the cut down
maybe I'll give it a try
just see how it does like why not right
I know people do it all the time yeah
I haven't been recording
but I could get it a different way
I was thinking more second Channel
but could be fun I think it could work
on this channel just because it's it is
Alden ring
and just do all the good moments
you know
I haven't seen anyone do this challenge
either I've seen plenty of challenges
but not like this
all right guys give me a title
give me a good title
it can't be wheel of level challenge
Elden Ring Thing can't be that
it's got to be like
uh
skill Lottery challenge
wheel of pain
yeah zero vigor
oh bro
zero Vigor challenge that's basically
where we're at yeah you're right
a massive thank you for gifting a
membership to Justin welcome Justin good
to have you appreciate it thank you
bungalist
massive you're a legend
appreciate you very much
Elden ring Pro gets destroyed by Fate
I was thinking more
I built an Elden Ring character
completely
by
luck
not like that
way too long yeah shorten that down
somehow
laughs
randomized stat challenge
yeah
well think of this
think of YouTube titles
what's gonna catch the most eyes mostly
the thumbnails so we'll work on the
thumbnail
which I like potatoes
potatoes idea where it's like uh my
character holding down is out his hand
and it's the wheel that's a good one
hey
so yeah yeah it's right this way nope
don't need anything buddy bait sucks
yeah I can't say fate because the people
think it's like Faith or something
don't need rage I haven't raged that
much
thumb Noob gets absolutely murdered by
fate and Elder and gone sexual 18 plus
gone insane there we go that's the one
that's the one
wheel of pain
Wheel of Fortune specs challenge
and that one doesn't roll off the tongue
very well
how about this
I played Elden ring
wait I hold on I had it and I lost it
I won the Elden ring Lottery
If I complete the challenge which I will
okay we're not gonna [ __ ] do that
Trump where we bait everybody
unlucky Elden ring Enthusiast gets no
bigger runt
I did this Elden ring challenge so you
don't have to
that's actually a good title
so we can leave it up to where they
think okay what is the challenge and
then they click on the video right maybe
we don't tell them exactly what the
challenge is until they click on the
video because the thumbnail is our
gigachad character holding the wheel in
its hand right like think of like this
so they'll know somewhat
but what if it's just like I did this
Elden ring challenge so you don't have
to
I turned Elden ring into a gotcha game
now that's like for anime right
see how hard it is to come up with a
title
it's really hard
make sure the wheel is blank
no It's gotta say It's gotta have stuff
on it
or they won't know what it is they'll
think it's a [ __ ] volleyball or
something
I did this wheelie hard challenge
did this really hard challenge
good good
we rarely receive fascinating so about
the bird if you have rise with us
gotcha is any game where you do lottery
for characters not just Anime is that
true I thought the meme was that it's
like all anime games
the
news the key
what do you guys think are we on track
for any any type of video here
dude if I could do challenge runs like
this all the time and just make videos
off those streams I could die happy
I could make content like it's none of
your business
lore videos are extremely hard to make
chat
like there's a reason why they take so
long
you will pull up ideas you've liked so
far
I mean my memory is that of a goldfish
so
this is a Japanese animated game no I
mean yeah you're not wrong
you're not wrong
I like the I did the challenge so you
don't have to idea I like making the
viewer wonder what the challenge is so
they have to click on it
right for them to understand what the
challenge is they literally have to
click on the video
and then I'll explain it right at the
beginning
we're gonna bait them pleasure to meet
you I am I don't need to talk to any of
these people I need to go in here
anime is an art style
it is absolutely
but yeah I wouldn't say Elden ring is
Anime but I I get what Trey's saying
it's like kind of like that
guys if the video thumbnail and title
flops we're all gonna have a discussion
together
you're like all right guys this flopped
what did we do wrong
let's discuss it as a team
and then you all go Jake it's your fault
and I go all right sorry
pretty much how that goes
all right we can get our five six and
seven here by the way
it went with my title okay what was
yours radicals specifically
I want to hear it still can't level
I'm waiting on radical's title
ow
Rando ring challenge
I like that it rolls off the tongue
pretty good
but it's not the title
winning the Elden ring Lottery that was
mine
can we get lucky to beat Elden ring how
about that
no that doesn't make sense
I did this challenge so I did this Elden
ring make sure Elden ring is in the
title chat
it helps with uh search history or
search searches if you have Elder ring
in the title
I guess we could just do Elden ring
challenge right
these things are [ __ ] terrifying
tortured Alvin oryx
Elden ring wheel of misfortune
that's on the right track
but I don't know if that's the one
that's pretty good
the Eldon wheel
I I don't think like you know if I was
like donkey
or I don't know someone's like four
million subscribers and I could just
make the title whatever
I I'm still having to go off search
es you know
I have to
Elden ring Rune wheel challenge
that that comes off much better than
wheel of leveling
like I have a title today I couldn't
even come up with that
Elden ring Rune wheel challenge
now that would be going against our uh
don't tell him what it is but I'm fine
like we don't have to do that by the way
that's just an idea
we don't have to not tell them what it
is
as well
actually got lost
uh
hey
[ __ ] you
Elven ring roon wheel challenge
it hints towards it but doesn't give
anything away really
that's my favorite one so far Joe that's
really good
press one and chat if you like that one
Joe's
dude I'm literally [ __ ] lost okay now
I'm not
right here
there's our six
big
that's a good one I think Joe's is gonna
win
wheel of runes that's kind of I matches
Joe's
I mean I just I just dealt with this
spinny [ __ ]
okay
stealing of viewers suggested video idea
right
I mean that would be truthful
Elden ring but every time I level up I
spin some weird wheel plus I have really
bad luck and new DLC
the get good challenge no
luckery challenge
luckery ain't a word
Elden ring wheel of rune
wheel of runes challenge
that's it right
guys I missed a stone didn't I somewhere
no no no I know where it is it's on the
it's up here
I'm stupid
Elden ring wheel of runes challenge
I really miss you guys
uh Logan have a great day at work dude
we'll see you back soon I might still be
streaming when you're done with work as
well as this is [ __ ] going right now
wheel of gift
oh doesn't roll
but luck decides build Elden ring
challenge but luck decides the build
how about I title it Elden ring decided
to [ __ ] me
perfect
foreign
that's a good one
can't cuss in a title unfortunately okay
there's our five we can get a seven
across the way here
it can I still do the glitch where I
jump up on the bridge
damn
Elden ring says no to Pro Gamer
Elden ring smashes me in more ways than
one
nice
Elden ring challenge but a wheel decides
my build
um
I still
okay
so I did this Elden ring challenge so
you don't have to or the title and wheel
of Misfortune as thumbnail texts
probably attracts clicks if you don't
give it away yeah I don't think we
should give it away either I'm kind of
on the fence with that
kind of on the fence
yeah Bridge got patched I can see that
thing's gone
um is there another way we can get in
there
no so we can't get seven yet but we can
go upgrade and beat the [ __ ] out of this
guy how about that huh
Elven ring wasn't prepared to cry
that's good I like cat's idea the cat so
if we if we go with the like Elden ring
wheel of runes challenge
then we're giving away everything about
the challenge in the in the title and
the thumbnail basically in the title
or we can bait people into what kind of
challenge is this
so they're like Cokes by the thumbnail
and also they don't really know what the
title means
now there's give and take with that
where people will be like uh
you know
they get annoyed that they don't
understand and then just don't click it
at all
well I took even about that what if
Elder ring was a casino
it's not bad
I guess we're going with Bloodhounds
Fang by the way I guess that's just what
we're doing
prison Town Church
yeah
then ring but I level like a noob
this guy the stream loving the title
ideas it's pretty fun assassin
isn't it hard though
it's hard being a YouTuber isn't it guys
tough job
roon roulette
Eldon roulette
oh
that is technically what we're doing
isn't it
Elden ring luck of the draw challenge
um
these are good these are we're getting
there we're definitely getting there all
right can I beat this guy
foreign
that's good damage
[Music]
he also does good damage
foreign
[Music]
damn
like Mozart in a Walmart
that's true
what's your favorite weapon in the game
I'm not gonna lie uh bloodhound's Fang
is up there
but uh I would say ruins great sword is
my favorite
wheel of runes mystery build pain
so the Eldon ring wheel of runes mystery
build pain
yeah
how about this Elden ring challenge was
painful
this Elden ring challenge hurt my soul
and then the thumbnail will have the
wheel in the hand
you can throw that far you [ __ ]
basic
you're not around not wrong
I really can't I can't [ __ ] up here guys
I can't [ __ ] up here if I get hit I die
pretty much
you know probably because we don't have
any vigor
we don't have any vigor
all right
bigger check
man
you know what I'm surprised that more
people in the chat haven't been like
just upgrade vigor
I'm happy you guys all understand the
challenge we're doing and I appreciate
your uh your intelligence
thank you if I were streaming this on
Twitch all of them would be like just
upgrade Vigor idiot
because they don't read titles over
there none of them
and now y'all are good never mind
[Music]
yep
that's that's my fault
[Music]
you doing fatty
why is he so fat
foreign
[Music]
that's an early stage too
thank you
that's so [ __ ] unlucky
tell me if you guys feel the same
he rolls for way too long
when he does
foreign
[Music]
right here right here yeah [ __ ]
[Music]
he's gonna start going brazy
yep
good
[ __ ]
let's go baby
easy first try not a hard challenge at
all
let's go see that's what I tried to do
three times was bait him behind the wall
and he kept doing that
Chad you know what all is also a really
good weapon that we could use here
is the serpent Hunter
it won't be very good against Molina
though
we'll see
great job thank you I appreciate your
support chat
Elden ring is hard let's make it harder
that's not bad
Elden ring challenge Rune rage
Rune rage
I don't dislike that that's that's not
bad Rune rage
they use serpent Hunter against Melania
they do
I remember trying to use serpent Hunter
against her and I was struggling really
hard but maybe I can get better
no I was using Bloodhounds playing
against her and I was having a really
hard time that's right
we'll see how we feel about serpent
Hunter
we'll have to go and get all the Bell
bearings
how about I let luck decide my Eldon
ring build
did that sound good
I let luck decide my Eldon ring build
that kind of rolled off good
how
yeah but she's a god though
that was not bad
luck is an actual stat I mean
technically that's Arcane but it's
called arcane
Elden ring but my build is RNG
that's pretty good that's good ghost
Elden ring but my build is RNG
I'm completely stuck
cool
okay these guys are [ __ ] me bro
it's Discovery oh that's right it's not
even luck it's discovery
I'm doing that I'm sorry I'm being a
[ __ ]
I let a wheel decide my Elder ring build
yeah but if we just say wheel
most people will just be like a wheel
what
good chance work instead of luck
um
it's not as good as luck
well that can be bad or good luck
praying to our in Jesus
these titles are funny but a lot of them
will not work
chance sounds worse than a title but is
more accurate than luck you're you're
right okay
we've got three levels
let's see what we get
wait let me bring it up on screen
please give me some health
this build is so weird man
[Applause]
give me some type of life
endurance
endurance
all right
last one
another endurance
I'm finding it ridiculous that we're
just not getting any vigor
any health it I can't even remember the
last time we got it it's nuts man
Jesus
big F's
I I this is basically I am at this point
a glass Cannon like my strength and
decks are pretty good with decent
endurance
but I have no Health you can kill me so
quick
now can we kill Reichard like this I
know all of reichardt's moves
but if I get hit I die
this is gonna be tough
it's doable but it's gonna be really
tough
let's go
that didn't hit
that was really close
nice
really good
[Applause]
really good
okay we gotta watch we gotta watch this
right like it it'd be silly if we didn't
watch this cutscene
I mean this is one of our alerts
round two
me every day when I wake up
[Laughter]
yeah why does the cutscenes in this game
freeze all the time
for everybody
see that freeze it's getting so long
together we will give up the very calm
you were half a second you were half a
second off Brent that was really good
bro oh my God
good stuff Brent
thanks for the two bucks man
foreign
yes
first try right card
let's go
first try
dang
Giga
can we get a Bunchy
get a bunch of gigas in the chat please
bunch of giggas I all I just need to see
a sea of gigas and me going like this
okay
thank you
this game's for babies
that's a giga
Giga Chad
182
000 runes guys
it's time to do some spinny spins
seven
he spins can we please get some health
For the Love of All That is
all that is Holy
please
upgrade my vigor
please
[Applause]
mind it is
number two
foreign
[Applause]
number three
please don't go to int thank you okay
that's pretty good
we will take decks
I'm fine with either one of these I
think it's endurance yep endurance okay
[Applause]
it happened oh my God it happened guys
oh wow
we got one
we got one let's go we are literally
still under 20 Vigor and we've beaten
Reichard
okay we've got one two more we've got
two more levels
two more spinny spins
go to endurance go to endurance go to
endurance
one more
one more
go to endurance go oh
literally it's three in the mind
three
how are how are we gonna beat morgot
right
okay
now here's the next question
do we want to use the serpent Hunter
or do we want to keep going with
Bloodhounds Fang
let's go grab our seven we can go get an
eight and a nine by the way
seven is
I can go
um
I can go
here
you want to keep going with the Fang
okay
whatever suits you I mean bolt suit
both are okay
I should have grabbed our seven earlier
you have to make a bloopers video cut of
this live stream I will try it okay
guys if that video flops
you're gonna get nothing but lore videos
forever
so I'll make sure don't flop
that's on you not me
serpenters too slow
we do have a bit more going on with
Bloodhounds Fang
all you gotta do is make sure you watch
the video on multiple devices uh watch
the entirety of the of it
like it comment on it and send it to
your friends
that's all
I hate you
um more than likely yes
pump
you're the content creator shake my head
yeah but my entire livelihood depends on
what you guys like
foreign
yes I am
YouTube algorithm is more d-forwarded
now on flops
more driven forward what what do you
mean Brent
what you saying Brent
that was probably just me being dyslexic
and not being able to understand so
um
grabbing the maps are always my favorite
part of the whole game I don't ever grab
the maps I'm sorry
lops Deez Nuts on your chin
thank you
did I deserve that
no specific ending Joe
oh that's the door to here oh I'm on the
wrong door
Lantern win never now I'm actively not
going to get a lantern
just don't kill me
it's a good one assassin
POV your local Denny's parking lot bro
I've never been to Denny's
never been
Lantern would have saved you
Maybe
I'm not doing any spells I guess I could
be a wizard alongside bluntout's Fang
couldn't I
the lantern is mad
if I had a lantern we could see what
Reichard looks like
he looks different from this guy this is
not reichardt is it I always thought
this was
that's right card
I don't need seed bed curse so I'm not
going over there
where's this door at
is it over here
it is
okay let's not die to this lady
excellent
we're in
now we're gonna go to caled and get an
eight and a nine
and then we're going to literally have a
plus nine Bloodhounds Fang
not bad in the slightest
that is here
if only you could
somehow generate light
yeah there should be like a flashlight
in this game man
you should have added flashlights
foreign
it would get me some bigger
all right
[Laughter]
what do you what are the requirements
for the blast when displayed
like it might anywhere near that
okay we got our nine
ladies and gentlemen we are in I think
we are about to start farming the rest
of this game actually never mind I don't
have any [ __ ] health
that's right
forgot about that part wow to lay out
your own
plus nine
need Faith 24 faith
we're at 18.
uh uh any items that I could use I mean
I haven't even looked at like my
amazing how if you don't actively seek
out armor in this game you're probably
not gonna get it
crazy
22 strength 15 decks 21 faith we could
do that
good
we'll see if we get there
um
we just need more faith
all right let's go start beating up
bosses man we gotta start flowing we
gotta start going man are there any
major bosses down there that we haven't
beaten no we beat Ronaldo we beat godric
Margaret radon
right card
we gotta go to the city
let's go
oh my god dude the dragon the dragon oh
no
the dragon Sentinel
what
[Music]
death birds are not major
we also have to go down and beat the
deer we could go down under
Bailey basement apostle
we could do that to get the uh
the god Slayer Greatsword which I
believe we can use
Maybe
Moon Queen we killed Ronaldo
ranala dead
oh yeah we have to go do fia's questline
as well
cause we gotta kill Porta sacks
we had to kill fortnite sex
have a good one Finn
thanks for hanging out
some light would be nice for us viewers
yeah yeah yeah well it's light out now
oh [ __ ] dick all right here we go
foreign
just like the start of the Stream
oh man just like the start of the Stream
oh
boy
hey booted came at the right time buddy
oh no the draconic tree Lancer
press one in chat if you guys want me to
buy a lantern
wait that's an
accident
I thought he was just going up like
that's the start man
he's beatable uh yeah I just can't get
hit because I'm a [ __ ] glass Cannon
foreign
foreign
[Music]
this is turning into a no hit run
if because if I get hit I die
so I guess I got hit a couple times and
didn't die
that was good though that was okay
we're gonna be fine
and that'd be fine
look he's already half health
he was already half health
[Laughter]
and I already have no health
I pressed Y Man
foreign
peaking currently currently peaking
run
keep doing that attack I like it I like
it when you keep doing it
I
I didn't like that one though
I didn't like that one
that lightning damage was rather
shocking
good one Joe
good one
you died thank you for reminding me Chad
what
I was on his [ __ ]
and he hit me
oh wait did it did I not pick up my
runes
are you even trying
yep
oh
oh my ruins are gone
that's not good
he's really hammering it into you
that was good
that was good
did somebody say to level Vigor and they
weren't being ironic
yeah he delayed the attack and it got me
he got me man
I'm somehow alive
[Music]
wow
thank you
man he twisted that [ __ ] around so
quick
well kind of like that
okay so when he goes stage two he he
will keep swinging he won't stop
he will not stop
accidental glass Cannon build Elden ring
wheel of chance that's actually a good
title
no I'm not using a summon
what
this is be this is quickly becoming the
hardest thing we've faced today
because it's just immediate death
holy
at least we have a good enough
weapon
man bro
[Laughter]
there's so many different variations of
his swings it's like there's no way to
tell what exactly he's doing he went
like this up like that and then went
That's crazy dude
there's so many different ways like it
was like a backhand
thanks Matrix appreciate that
I [ __ ] rolled game
the physic takes so [ __ ] long
foreign
foreign
come on
dude that boss is so hard when you can't
get hit
wow
first try
not even hard
yeah
I just realized should I go get a great
room maybe
let's go get a great Rune guys
did I at least get the bridge okay I did
oh man
didn't even heal
let's hope that was the hardest one it's
not
I'll tell you that right now it's not
foreign
let me spend these runes first just in
case something weird happens it's
definitely enough for a wheel spin
all right let's see
let's see it could be one or two just
one all right
please
give me more Health game
stop please
[Applause]
like it it couldn't have been closer
dude
it couldn't have been closer it that oh
my God
oh
that hurt my soul that hurt every part
of my body
oh my God
oh it's personal this point come on
please
the spinny wheel hates vigor
oh
it's better this way
how we're gonna be here all night trying
to do this
we might have to come back tomorrow
oh my God
we've been at this for six hours
this video finna hit
it's funny I'll tell you that
at first it was funny and now it's
depressing
it's the best comment I've heard today
Joe's got all the best comments bro
[Music]
at this point it's too late for Vigor
you're right like do we doesn't morgot
only give you health I think
it's been six hours oh yeah
Joe these nuts
nuts Who
yeah we're doing every remembrance boss
you know it's going to hit when another
YouTuber does the same challenge
yeah
has no one done this before
I haven't seen it personally but that
doesn't mean it hasn't happened
Joe mama
why didn't I say that
my brain is dead
I said Joe these nuts like the Joe mama
obviously
someone did a few months back
are you just saying that
I've seen many a challenge but not this
one
[Music]
it's a fun challenge it's all luck based
[Music]
Joe Mama on these nuts okay
you watched their video okay well I'm
gonna do it too
[Music]
got the Ronnie questline for all
remembrance bosses yeah well no it's
just FIA
it's just via we don't have to do
Ronnie's questline for that well yeah we
do for astel which we still don't have
to do Ronnie's questline for that
we might as well
yeah
might as well slap this on and hit up
hit a rune Arc
where's the part where you're drunk read
the title again
then come back to me
there are people playing two versions at
the same time using a controller and a
Dance Pad others are only attacking the
bosses using a kick Ash of War
I did see the girl using the dance pad
and the controller at the same time
that's kind of [ __ ] insane
[Music]
you will now die to fall damage
yep
she has my eternal respect
she has mine as well
all right you guys ready to lose your
maiden
let's get this emote in the chat just
preemptively
maidens
My Utmost thanks
for bringing me to the base of the earth
tree here
I can govern my own movement and thus
the Accord is fulfilled I shall depart
to ascertain the purpose I was given
farewell I shall leave torrent
and the power to turn runes into
strength
here
with you I wish you luck
in realizing your ambition
you have fought long and hard I have no
doubt you will become Elden Lord
may you take the throne
that's me baby
yo Trey
thank you man closer to drunk Jake what
are we at now
thank you bro
I really appreciate it I really
appreciate the 10 Gifted Man that's very
very kind of you I appreciate it dude
and Joe got one let's go
hello let's go
thank you thank you Trey get some W's in
the chat for Trey police
he's a homie
[Music]
an absolute homie
YouTube has to go find a find a bunch of
people to get gifted
okay so I can't jump down there anymore
right
I think they patched it
[Music]
we need a w emote don't we have one
me
[Music]
hello
hello
yep if you got a gifted from trade or
Hal
I call him Trey because that's what I
call them
um make sure to say thank you
okay golden ruin
did I kill this Avatar
the answer is yes
that was dumb
shouldn't have done that
foreign
not have any viewers that aren't members
I mean that's the goal I'm pretty sure
we can still gift memberships even if we
go over the amount of members
we're out of uh viewers
what are his stats now low vigor
that's all you need to know
okay we got a big room there
okay
let's go 88k
please game just stop [ __ ] me
please
three levels guys let's go
don't do it to me again
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
it happened
it literally happened and I can't
believe it
okay
okay
all right
okay
Grim pigeon thank you for becoming to
tarnished thanks for becoming a member
appreciate you man
welcome welcome W's in the chat
appreciate you again if you're a new
member make sure to go to the community
tab or the membership tab
and go to the uh
you'll you can get a access to the
members only Discord okay make sure you
join that because a lot of new people
are joining that and it's really fun
okay one more
join up baby join up
sit on decks sit on decks
that might that that was the best poll
[Applause]
we've had in a while
that was good
based on
pass spins we are going to take that all
right good stuff boys
big
do we not have a w emote
can I can I just [ __ ] chill for a sec
oh it's GG that's right
I thought that one was the W all right
I'll make a w emo
that also means we need an L emote
go ahead and run away from that guy
right now
all right
um
I think I said this at the beginning of
the stream we've gotten so many new
members that we've unlocked 18 more
emote slots by the way
the more members we have the more emotes
we're allowed to upload
so
that's another incentive by the way
I just got stabbed
that's a big Rune as well [ __ ] bro
yeah right the path to this area is
climbing up a dead dragon's Wing it's
freaking awesome
can we get a dedicated Lord 4 quad emote
no
you can
[Music]
hi Stan
well we gotta be god-free that's right
I always forget about this boss
every time
without fail
what ending we running I'll let the chat
decide
we'll do whatever they want
is
is class to do sex a remembrance boss
Andrew Tate's been arrested
really
what happened
well I can think of a lot of reasons but
why did he get arrested
[Applause]
oh he got arrested for human trafficking
[Music]
all the tick tock kids are gonna be mad
what oh
that was my bad
yes he is okay got you got you gotcha
that one was my bad
this is not a hard fight and I was
dodging like a literal noob
I will take the L for that one and we
lost a rune Arc I'm upset
I'm confident I'm not even gonna pick up
my
I'm gonna pick up my runes now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I've never seen him reach out at you
like that before you guys see that
he like reached out
I haven't seen that before that's that's
kind of weird
lore was
okay
yeah I should not be getting hit by that
boss at all I'm usually very good
against Godfrey okay
here we go guys we've got two more
levels two more spinny spins let's get
it let's go bam
it's happening it's happening
it it's happening
we're doing it
it's all coming together it's all coming
together Big W
Big W
Trey I think that was was that a late
gifted
I I can't believe it
I
[Applause]
um I'm shocked
wow
okay
okay
wow
all right
double double bigger pickup guys
let's go
I think he's cheating shut I'm not
[ __ ] cheating
shut your [ __ ] mouth you see the spinny
Spence I show it to you
our luck is turning
[Music]
I demand a respin why because I got
lucky for once
Landell has been very kind to us
pre-recorded spins I can't even with
y'all right now
foreign
look at how perfectly I thought that
I'm just getting better
I'm just getting better baby
we need to maintain spin Integrity as I
have been doing
I will never skip the morgot cut scene
ever
you know what I just uh you know what I
just thought of that kind of put me in a
slight major depression
right now just just now
the fire Giant
I just thought of the fire Giant and got
sad
I think I'd rather fight Melania
than the fire Giant
okay let's get melon up in this [ __ ]
we go
graceless tarnished
why does he call me graceless when I
literally was given Grace what is thy
business with these Thrones is he just
an idiot
[ __ ]
godric the golden
the twin prodigies mikola and millennia
General radon
freighter reichardt
I mean I know he's in Omens Ronnie but
he called me graceless
yeah
he's one to talk beautiful traitors oh
he doesn't think you're worthy enough I
mean I got it so like that like doesn't
make sense
who remembers when he did this it used
to light on fire
but then they took it out
villagers
emboldened by the flame of ambition
because it didn't make sense lore wise
why he would be able to do that
felt by King Morgan
you didn't know you had Grace oh Kings
Maybe
able to tell
like he'd be able to tell man
it's just the way he said it graceless
it doesn't make sense
foreign
that delay was so long
[Music]
foreign
huh
the Thrones
stand on your curse such as
shall not be forgiven this
oh
foreign
ER
I went for it
was very finish him
kill him
please
dude that was so good I thought we were
gonna first try them I thought and then
he just [ __ ] held that [ __ ] up there
like like he's redone holding the Stars
up holding that [ __ ] holding holding
holding and then he smacks me
delayed ass [ __ ] attacks man
that's all it takes
I'm this confident though
that's right I popped it let's go
let's go
Moana you did great do better
[Music]
I hate this fight I'm so bad at this
fight
I can never like there's barely any
openings
too late
got him
Melina just staggered him
that was so clutch
what
I literally dodged into it
I should have stood near a tree
no not worth
no
the positioning is so annoying
she in the wall
no
no [ __ ] shot
it's just me and him
I'm gonna take the heel we got one more
in the reserve
go
we [ __ ] traded
we [ __ ] traded
holy [ __ ] we traded oh my God
ounce
we got that bro I went for it I was like
I did the first Bloodhounds finesse and
I hit him and I'm debating like do I do
it because he's gonna hit me and I'm
like [ __ ] it
oh my God that was [ __ ] awesome
yes dude
and I I can't truly die so that makes
sense lore wise too
wait
wait
um
oh wait what's that no one cares
okay let's move on
giga
hello again I love how my character
looks like Giga too
confess with you
you are unable to enter the Earth tree
I'm a little toxic sorry he tried to
kill me guys okay
the Thorns are impenetrable a husk of
the earth trees being
that spurns all that exists without the
only way to stand before the Elden ring
and become the Elder Lord
is to pass the thorns my purpose
serves to Aid in that very Act so I'd
like you to undertake a New Journey
with me I think we should go underground
and kill the ancestral Spirit to get the
remembrance
upon the snowy mountain tops of the
Giants
then
I can set the Earth tree aflame and
guide you
why does she have this to becoming Eldon
law
why does she randomly have this
medallion
and why did she think we could get
inside the tree
before we fought morgot and now she
doesn't but she just happens to have
this
isn't that weird
I think it's weird chat
all right
let's do some spitty spins
right Stan
because it's in the game files okay yeah
she has an office right right okay
let's do some spinny spins
all right
please more Vigor for the fire Giant
please we can level up only four times
we actually beat morgot at level 73
that's pretty good I'm not gonna lie
okay
yeah we have to fight sewer Moog do we
not really
Faith bro I mean our faith is actually
decently High
could help down the road
okay
well now it's really good
okay
no
mine
[Applause]
Faith Build yo what is this build
what what is this what would you guys
consider this at and then we get Arcane
I'm that was awful
[Applause]
that was [ __ ] awful
[Applause]
that could have been the worst one
what is this we have 20 Vigor 22 mind 19
endurance 24 strength 24 decks 14 inch
20 faith and 15 arcane
it's a giga build
bro
[Laughter]
okay how how much Faith do I need to use
God slayer's great sword and is God
slayer's great sword really all that
good
I say [ __ ] it like we have Bloodhounds
Fang it's annihilating people let's just
keep going until we like need to do
something else you know let's just keep
it rolling
I say but we should go underground
we shouldn't
uh yeah here
no it sort of sucks that's what I
thought but I've heard a few people's
tell me to use it
you have enough to do blasphemous
uh I have 20. didn't you guys say I need
22.
22.
so I guess we still want Faith because
Blasphemous blade is really good right
it's working so far we're just gonna
keep doing what works
we have the strength we have the decks
we need one more faith then
right we literally need one more faith
that's crazy
I think
once we get enough for Blasphemous blade
I think we should switch to that we need
one more faith
but we will use bloodhound's Fang until
we can't anymore
bet
so that I'm making with myself
because I feel like bloodhound's Fang is
definitely gonna level out at some point
like it's gonna be quite hard to use
do I have a faith talisman
wait I do have a faith talisman
when I killed uh
Anastasia
no that just raises holy attack
never mind
yeah we're doing all remembrances
where can I get a face talisman
want to say props you Jake for things
exploding in the last few days you're
consistent and positive attitude are
paying off oh
that's very nice for you to say I'm glad
you think so I'm doing my best out here
I'm not gonna lie I got in a much better
mood after we hit a hundred thousand
subscribers
on Christmas
that kind of lit up my whole world to be
honest so thank you Chad
because we were at 90 000 subscribers
for a very long time and just to get
that Milestone felt really good
it felt nice
I am getting naked for this fight I
don't care if anyone calls me a [ __ ]
for doing so
foreign
s
heirloom's in the ruins where you find
shabiri Grape and lorenia
I think I know where that is
purified ruins got it
I mean we can go there we or we can get
lucky
do fist only trust me we've tried it
doesn't do [ __ ] you just hit each other
for forever
watch I don't even care if he starts
hitting me
literally can't hurt me a little bit
bye-bye
get him out of here
I'm too busy to [ __ ] around
all right
foreign
Maybe
while that enemy had no Vigor I wonder
why that sucks no level pain
that fight seems so misplaced
wait
what is this
the world may never know
okay we should get the Finger Slayer
blade right we don't really need to
I also don't want to use summons
is my like unless it's like a part of
the fight like radon
nothing Stone okay we can come back to
that later
foreign
gotcha
okay
there's so many animals
let's get that number down
[Music]
[ __ ]
I really don't want to fight him
I don't want to fight the rules
yep walking runes baby walking runes
I don't feel I don't want I don't think
we have to kill the other one because
it's not a remembrance boss
feels like yeah
[Music]
enhanced shot
oh I've heard of that one
never knew that was down there yeah dude
did I get all of them
is that it no no no there's this one
oh my God
okay
would you guys rather fight the the
double gargoyles
or
do we do Ronnie's entire questline to
avoid them
the test
actually don't we have to anyway
I don't think I have D for the Gargoyles
now
nothing wrong with wife
[Music]
dog I didn't even hit you yet
what
yes I have to suffer that's gonna be
great
a fight that spams poison
oh my God
oh my God
I can't even hit this thing
yeah I have to do Virgo's no matter what
okay
dude why is it so annoying right now
oh my God
bro
I'm gonna have a stroke
I I'm sorry but I've never even given
this boss a second thought and that time
I was just like I I can't hit you
you skip gar girls third Tower Ronnie's
part of the quest line yeah but don't
you have to go down there you have to
get past them
well no okay there is another way we
don't have to fight the Dual gargoyles
we could beat other Moog
we could beat other Moog
and go through the secret entrance down
in the sewers to get to fias area to get
down there without having to fight the
Gargoyles
it's annoyingly complicated to explain
does it get health back
no that's when it sucks up all the
spirits
Yeah by frenzied Flame
foreign
man just give me a little distance bro
why did I just hear a phone
I just heard a phone ring in game
there we go
that was easy
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened on
that first attempt I couldn't do
anything where are my runes at
with your Vigor I'd rather go do that
though the Moog fight
I too love hunting Canadians
I love Canadians in general they're all
very nice very sweet
guys
my new phone is here
oh
that's exciting
all right
I'll set that up later probably tomorrow
because God damn all right
um
I mean I guess we go here right
just can't roll Reinhardt no we want to
go here
I got the new iPhone
I've had this giant Samsung for like a
year
I'm kind of over it let's go back to an
iPhone
here's the other part of uh all the like
because I've been trying to date
recently
and you know a lot of it's like online
and you know it'll be like a dating app
and then they'll be like hey give me
your number I'll give up I'll give them
my number and I will tell you 98 of the
girls are like why do you not have an
iPhone
all of them they'll be like
why are my texts green
and it'll piss them off
that it's not blue
does that make sense
yeah grinder okay we got two levels two
levels
look at all these girls assuming like
this is so annoying
like who cares you know
there it is Blasphemous blade acquired
that's huge
so now we don't have to go do all that
Faith [ __ ] let's go guys
big
and get a little bit more strength in
there okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay
that was good
iPhones are way too expensive well I
switched to T-Mobile no I didn't want to
spin nope no one see
you have no idea what it landed on I
didn't mean to spin
okay
okay
do we go get the Blasphemous blade now
which I have to go duplicate the
remembrance right
I have to go duplicate the remembrance
uh it was mined
[Music]
how'd you know
for real look
wait
[Music]
how did you know
wow
okay where did I already do this
Mausoleum down here
I think so right
this was you know five hours ago
I didn't
I did okay uh where where's another one
with a bell it has to be a bell
uh
oh I knocked it down but didn't have a
remembrance you're right
I did it well beforehand oh good [ __ ]
also I can only do one at each one right
or can I come back here with another one
and do it again
I did use it
dang it
I did
lorenia North is that one with a bell
yeah it's one only
I don't think this one has a bell yes it
does
you dumb [ __ ]
sorry
oh piss
okay at least it's down here
foreign
yeah I have to wait for this one
so we will probably have to go to EG as
well
to get uh
somber's one through four again for
Blasphemous played
I just want to have it as an option
it's not even close to where we want it
to be is it
nope it's walking the way we want though
it's walking the way we want though
foreign
[Music]
got to do it like this
there we go
[Music]
foreign
please don't hurt me Daddy
ugh
giga
Giga paint
yeah I think we got lucky with how close
it was to where we needed it to be
okay
reichardt's Blasphemous blade
let's [ __ ] go let's [ __ ] go bro
that's so big that we have that
thanks
you know Skip Skip Skip Skip skip
uh Power of a remembrance
the Blasphemous blade
absolutely massive
big dick
huge penis okay
see what we can do
it's good enough you can do it
one
okay we need a two
we need a two banger
and a four banger let's go get it
we need a two Banger and a four banger
inequivocally busting
let me up
braved
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
two
and a four
excellent
some
uh strengthen
oh I need runes
oh smell my how many do I need it was
like none can I sell anything to you of
course not all right going back
going back
also I need to turn in my uh
my bells to see what we can do there
you wanna
one of these
yeah you do
1875 and we're 18 28.
we're gonna have three runes
let's go turn in our Bells
so what's better
Blasphemous blade plus four or
Bloodhounds Fang plus nine
probably depends on the situation
rolled in the hay team okay
these are for normal s smithing stones
are you kidding me
wow we're weak
Blasphemous because HP
all right we'll test it out who we
fighting now
are we fighting
the fire Giant
or
or
or
did I not damn it
okay
let's get the Finger Slayer blade
I don't feel like we need to do this
chat
nope I'm Going Underground
we don't need to do this
we don't need to
yes Stan we're always fighting gun deer
every day all day we might have to go at
this again tomorrow chat
it's getting late bro this is a long
stream for YouTube
long stream
sewer Moog is underground that's where
I'm going
a bit girthy around the middle too
yo true
I saw a 12-hour stream the guy losing
his sanity over five nights at Freddy's
off the fight the Pooh and pissman
the poo and the pissman
a little poo in the piss
so is it gonna piss you guys off that I
always get lost down here
like I think last time I went to sewers
on stream I literally made people so
[ __ ] mad that I didn't know where I
was going
like they were screaming at me
congratulations on 100K and 250 members
dog we're at 228 members I don't know
what you're talking about bro
hey maybe don't spam that in my face
there's a skip
no
I'm sorry I'm sorry but you are faced
the complete opposite direction uh
whatever bro
whatever bro
there's a skip what do you mean
oh it's 229 sorry
I might change this font I feel like
it's hard to read the numbers
[Music]
I got show slam I'm really glad I picked
up those three runes by the way
the Keats you skip the sewers
listen I'm confused at what you guys are
talking about so I'm just gonna
do this
I did that out of anger because I [ __ ]
up my jump
foreign
[Music]
kind of uses a lot of FP guys
I hate it down here so much
look it up okay is it like a glitch skip
or a skip
foreign
are you lost already bro yeah little bro
I am
yes
there's a sombre right there
it doesn't even hurt them
God damn
oh my God
I start going up the [ __ ] ladder and
there's this giant Omen [ __ ] in my
face
just a giant gaping butthole
God I hate this area
okay just don't fall
not a glitch just a jump
all right explain it explain it to me
how to do it through chat
so I can try and do it and [ __ ] it up
I could really use a [ __ ] Lantern
right now
foreign
oh my God
[Music]
I I think I should just die
just look it up no that's not as fun
above the ladder where the Omens killed
you and through the door is where the
skip is okay so I still have to get
there
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
sorry
don't die don't die
why why is my character just not doing
it why
please stop
swinging holy
oh my God
no
holy [ __ ]
oh my God
that was so annoying
okay
so through here right
I'll open the gate too
how hard is the skip
because I don't know what it is Angel I
don't know why I didn't come up on the
second ladder the one with the beetle at
the beginning
putrid corpse at the end you will see an
arch with the view to an elevator to
moog's area
okay
okay and thank you for the two months
angel I appreciate it man
so right down here
said with the beetle
beetle
Samuel says
on the second ladder the one with the
beetle at the beginning future chords at
the end you will see an arch with a view
to elevator to moog's area
[Music]
um like maybe I have to go to a certain
spot to see it
at the end okay
like here
's the corpse
oh he's alive
sorry
foreign
jump in that ledge this right here
okay
now what's up
oh
under me how do I go under here
I was right okay thanks
I'm gonna go back here now
what do I do from here that's my next
question
I just jump
do I have to jump in a specific way do I
have to jump out do I have to roll out
stand in the window Edge jump to the
cage below you to the left
I see
I see it I see it
how do I get to that
jump hugging the wall
like this
I just jump right there
do I have to Sprint
very close
I see what we need to do
good
good
and we opened up a shortcut so that's
good too
it's this way sorry
might take a few lives all right
as long as I can skip the entirety of
the sewer I am okay with that
I am A-Okay with that son
okay
here
all right thank you chat I will figure
this out
I think I need to jump just a little bit
further
this is hard
legit hard
no way I really jump into it really
no way
oh hug the wall on the landing
well I would yeah no [ __ ] okay all right
I won't do it like that
wait I have to run
I get momentum anyway
that time I went too far bro
I bet if I jumped without running I
would have nailed it
who said run for momentum
never mind
I I think if I just hug the wall and
jump around it
I'll just go right in it
I think I will
everyone said to run
nah I think it was just you
foreign
is that not it
or am I jumping to that ledge on the
left
my character didn't jump
that shit's so annoying
to the top of the cage rim of the
elevator and roll in yeah okay that's
what I already thought
okay I got it stop confusing me now
I get what we're trying to do
thank you Sam
true
idea is to not die that's that's very
true
very true
I've I must have been a millimeter from
getting in there
that that looks so clean
man
what do I need bigger shoes and I would
have made that
might have been patched
that looked too close by the way Chad
that that looked honestly perfect
and I did not get in there
oh I did overshoot it once true
that was a slight overshoot too am I am
I right in saying that maybe I can just
jump around the corner without running
probably
try and find out yeah I guess I should
just give it a shot
all right
I just I just wasn't I just wasn't
looking like that that's a death like
that's how I die in Elden ring
falling to my death
guys this is really hard
foreign
you guys made this sound like it was
gonna be easy
I think I do have to run to get the
proper momentum
I think I would have made it to the
elevator if I just followed the normal
route at this point
all right I won't overthink it I'm just
gonna do it
I won't think I'll just do
ready
I mean I did just go for it
now that was taking forever
it's fairly easy okay
foreign
back on
I don't think that's gonna do anything
what okay
I was closest when I had the weapon on
anyway
foreign
yep
we got it
first try
okay what's better against Moog what
hounds Fang or Blasphemous blade
this is fake mode Moog too
it's [ __ ] mode
[Music]
hey I have a good one Joe thanks for
hanging out man
Bang
foreign
blade we give you HP pack
I mean that was not good
we'll try the Blasphemous blade right
here we'll try it right here
that wasn't great I could have you know
done better
bye Joe
another joke
I don't know about that Christian
foreign
huh
I think he's weak to bleed chat not fire
he's uh quite strong against fire
go ahead and go back to this
let's go back to this
at yep good one Stan yep yep
gone
weak to bleed
definitely not resistant against bleed
why did he do that
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
big
come on
he accepted defeat
y'all see that
he stood there and accepted that I was
better than him
oh my God he was just like
he stared
wow all right good good good
he's pretty weak to bleed
Melina
huh
if you intend to claim oh she can say it
here I thought you had to go lower life
in there is if you would please I wish I
didn't skip that that's that's cute
dialogue
I think he accepted that I was
dominating him
any any yeah he's just done
throwing that on uh okay guys you ready
for some spinny spins
definitely time for some spinny spins
okay
we've got two spinny spins
let's go
he gives you 100K down there that's
pretty cool
all right Dex we'll take it we'll take
it big spin
I wouldn't mind vigor
wouldn't mind some more Health but we'll
take it
ah
well this will be good if we're using
the Blasphemous blade I'm cool with mind
I'm good with that that's good
okay
I'd call that a mid
kind of mid spinny spins
um but we'll take it
good
more FP more poggers
also where Where is the secret area to
get to uh fias area from here
where is it I don't know
do I have to go all the way down
I think I do
oh God
[Music]
um
okay here we go guys
we might be here a while
I'm starting a poll
everyone get ready
[Music]
am I gonna first try this yes or no
[Music]
first try yes or no
[Music]
really
foreign
what
you guys are a little nuts
this is generous
I could have swore y'all would have said
no
I would have swore
[Music]
could have swore hold on
wait [ __ ]
dude what is happening my phone went
okay
oh my God
[Music]
annoying okay ear votes in okay you're
all saying yes
I can't believe you all believe in me I
I appreciate that
thank you that's very sweet
[Music]
that's very kind that you think I can do
this in a single try
it's time for a new phone definitely
[Music]
definitely bro
foreign
[Music]
is this the one I can roll to
no
[Music]
do I just jump to this one
like this normal bass jump
I'm killing it right now I'm absolutely
annihilating the video game right now
this one I roll
I'm not going to though
okay
okay
[Music]
before
[Music]
I'm
42 sure I can roll to that one just a
roll
foreign
there's a reason I said 42 percent
we're right back at it
right back in The Fray
[Music]
almost died
almost died
I guess it was a fell omen
that's funny
[Music]
do you guys think that they put this
violinist here
because they knew people were gonna
struggle heavy with this as like a joke
they definitely did right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's right
what
[Music]
I don't want to do this on keyboard
my character had a [ __ ] stroke in the
goddamn corner
[Music]
almost fell
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I don't
wanna talk yeah yeah
don't bruh me chat
I will fart on your mom
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we got to come up with 18 new emote
ideas
[Music]
okay just do do it
[Music]
why do people think I'm drunk
[Music]
is this the back step one
like I backstep
and I go right there
stand
[Music]
nobody knows
okay
just jump
let's see what jump let's do a little
jump let's do a little jumpy jump
foreign
okay
this is the back step one
not even close
I had a whole foot off that thing bro
damn
I have a question why are we down here
what are we doing down here
do we want to do this
yay or nay chat
or the sex oh that's right where's the
Secret Door is it here
here here
is it over here
oh opposite from Grace
here
[Music]
here
there it is ladies and gentlemen [ __ ]
the twin gargoyles I don't want to fight
them
I don't wanna
it's a bad boss okay I think this is
fair
I'll say it
twin gargoyles bad fight
bad fight
it's not fun
oh I gotta deal with some ants though
huh
didn't know about this I didn't either
until chat told me that told me
look at my confidence in platforming
with torrent though look at this
look at that speed
it's just because I have another jump oh
[ __ ]
go go go
go
I think I'd rather fight godskin Duo
than the Valiant gargoyles no cap
no Cappy on a stacky
let's go squalor
there it is
that goat's got some great parkour
skills
it is a good goat
foreign
place for an archery Avatar to be
foreign
we're fine without it
also we need to go like get a hug from
FIA and do all that [ __ ]
we gotta go get our hugs
and I fight these guys earlier will it
just let me go over to Godwin and
nothing will happen
or do I not even need to get my hugs and
Thea will just be there
that I don't know
the wheels being okay potato it's being
okay
are hugs required
Golden Ash award I think we're okay for
now Andrew
goddamn I've been live seven and a half
hours
there is a mausoleum here that's true we
should do that
hey we're about to find out
foreign
ER in the lands between
my streamer
do we have an emote that's like a heart
no we should have like a
a love emote of some kind
you remember that
all right let's see what happens
Torrance platforming is the best however
your normal character is ass
peace and love true
didn't I have one of those on Twitch I
don't remember Stan
all right we're still here
I I literally got so staggered that I
couldn't move I was spamming roll and my
character did not move
wow that hey any pvpers out there use
that whatever the [ __ ] that was
I couldn't move at all
man
this is gonna be the true Vigor check
foreign
he knows how to dodge
[Music]
foreign
really hard
[Music]
this [ __ ] game okay
foreign
I feel like I should go Bloodhound blood
thing
or whatever
went out right before me yes
[Music]
I thought I'd hit both at the same time
man
I thought I'd swing and hit them both
feels bad dude such a long annoying ass
rolling all the way over there too
heavy fire resistant
man
pain
it's like trying to find a window to
switch over
Jesus
bye
foreign
[Music]
that one literally just spawned in later
than the other one
hit
foreign
why is what taking so long some random
dude
do you want to try this go for it man
good night Stan
I didn't expect him to buff like that
and then uh
jump immediately afterward
I thought he would like still be in the
buff animation
this boss
I have no [ __ ] Health dumbass or
whatever
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yeah all right
I had no stamina holy [ __ ]
oh my God
that little [ __ ] thing staggers the
hell out of me
oh everything staggers me
man
holy [ __ ]
everything just makes me go
man
apparently I have zero poise
I feel like I was getting hit by a
[ __ ] morgot and I wasn't moving
getting staggered for that long
these are just some nerds
bye Taryn
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign why does he take longer to spawn
than the other ones
and my [ __ ] [ __ ] just I guess I was
out of stamina I don't even know
I was out of Santa
[Music]
[ __ ]
we'll take it
no no no
the [ __ ] staggers oh my God
my character just gets annihilated after
every little touch he'll just poke me
and I'm just like
I'll take if I get touched it's over
like the other one will just come in and
end it
I've only we've only tried this like
four times and I'm already more
frustrated than any other boss we fought
today
this isn't even a hard fight I I I can
tell you're trolling and you're just
your timing is so bad that I'm Banning
you imagine read the [ __ ] room oh
that annoyed me
just really bad timing you're just gone
I never want to hear you again
[Music]
not you block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
and now he's dead we don't even got to
deal with him
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
kid in chat and we did it look at that
all it took was Banning the annoying
[ __ ] chat
holy [ __ ]
God damn okay we got one spinny spin
One Singular
spinny spin yes I banned some random
dude
I did it's [ __ ] annoying
[Applause]
we'll take it
not bad
all right
I mean yeah you can troll like there's
nothing wrong with trolling but shut the
[ __ ] up you know what I mean like you
can all like he's bad if he was trying
to troll he's bad at it
another level no no way okay we we
definitely have to go get hugs by the
way
we we do have to get hugs to initiate
for you
um
yeah okay let's do it
the challenge is very fun it's very RNG
oriented but I'm having a good time
it's hard it's great I am circumscribed
perhaps you doing so and you do you
think where I come from ah
oh
chat the Cowboys play soon yeah we we
got we gotta we got it in stream
somewhat soon
you are
very warm what did some random dude say
he uses trolling and it's just awful
timing
what you felt light up inside
though it is but a fleeting thing I am
afraid come back to me should you
require another I will take you in my
arms
as often as you need
the fingers player blade
we don't
yes I I am a fan of the Cowboys I watch
the Cowboys
I picked an NFL team to follow and it
was the Cowboys
take that as you will
I am pleased to see you again would you
like a blessing would you like wait do I
have to get the Bold against blessing
out first
before I hug her and it takes forever to
get out of the animation
I'm just gonna do it
Cowboys will end the wheel of torture I
mean we'll come back to it tomorrow
let's go right back at it again tomorrow
zero this
zero so I live in St Louis and I used to
be a Rams fan and then they moved to LA
and I had to pick a team and I picked
the Cowboys
I am pleased would you like there's
probably a no but whatever
it's one a.m here in the UK am I mate
watching drunk as [ __ ] now thanks for
the Stream
you got it bro it's 1am in Europe
or the UK yeah yeah
yeah you are so
very warm beside the YouTube title yet
for stream highlights
I think we're just gonna do uh
we got a lot of good ideas but we didn't
decide on anything though
yeah we saw Tay got arrested
too hurt to stick with the Rams it just
doesn't feel the same
so I would
I'd like to survive
okay to you okay okay okay
was my team and I was young it's time
for Irwin Smith
oh in the time of Irwin Smith Aikman
yeah I got you
wait why do we care about Tate getting
arrested
it's like the third person who's come
and chat and said that
zelia is he an important person or
something
I've seen him on Tick Tock or whatever
and that's it
2 A.M in the Netherlands
I'll go live in the morning if we don't
We're not gonna finish tonight so I'll
go live in the morning at some point
[Music]
unless you
oh man how would you like if you're
inclined then I'll introduce
okay
it will lead you most don't care okay
that's what I thought
well how did you well I know very why
don't Iris good work
okay and now he's dead as hell
getting messed up
we don't okay I guess I okay
thus stolen and now though
we live in what right hours what
remembrancies do we have left
um
we beat Redan
ranallah
godric
morgot Reichard
so that leaves
fire Giant
uh we beat the the moose
The ancestral spirit
um
is it just fire Giant
Melania and mo so and then Melania and
Moog of course
Melania Moog
we'll have to do all that tomorrow
we beat the deer
already
oh placidusacks malakath yeah okay it's
so hard to keep track all this [ __ ] all
right
let's beat four to sacks we need to beat
four to sacks we need to be astul
which
technically we don't need
to continue Ronnie's questline to fight
astral correct I don't think we do
because we found a way down without the
thing
yes
okay
all right
here
yeah we already killed the deer
two tries two tries
let's forget asshole's a part of it
uh I knew you what is it do you denial
it's probably gonna be our last boss
tonight chat I gotta I gotta
we've been streaming a long time today
I want to be held I am the guy comb yet
used
yeah we can do Essa without running
the most metal dragon fight of all time
are you guys cool if I turn the music
all the way up
Blast Your eardrums have you ever seen
the phone twins out there isn't it wait
[ __ ] I I forgot about the death Mark
dude
oh my God I forgot about the when God
that's the whole point
will you still
damn it all right
uh
here we go
yep here we go
we're going
we're gonna do this so fast
you guys all blink
and it'll it'll be it'll be it'll be
done
lit
Ronnie's questline does not take very
long
what we gotta do from this point
I I never have to watch a full football
game by the way like I don't have to
watch the entire football Cowboys game
but we have been streaming eight hours
today that's kind of a long time I'm
also starving I could use some food
yeah I think we got plus seven
Blasphemous from these Somers we picked
up
actually I think I found an eight as
well
Domino's Pizza dude I live in the middle
of nowhere I'm not gonna or like you we
can't order out here
I can't wait to move into my apartment
in a couple weeks
so that I can like
actually do things outside of this
we live in the middle of nowhere out
here
can't order pizza can't order food it
takes weight it would be like I wouldn't
be home like let's say I went and got
McDonald's
I would not be home for an hour and a
half
it takes that long
foreign
we'll get to you
do they even deliver
Ed
you're 12 hours from a Mickey D's how is
that possible
I see why you turn to 700 of Elden ring
with nothing that close huh
what is that what
wait this isn't gonna open
oh I got you yeah
guys that's gonna be it for me tonight
I gotta go all the way back and run back
we'll do it tomorrow man
we will stream tomorrow okay
tomorrow morning I'll be on again we'll
go again all right
for now I'm gonna watch football I'm
gonna go eat some food that's a nice
eight hour stream
darn it it does be too much work
um so thanks for being here thank you
for all the support we got a ton of new
members today just uh just like
yesterday so let's keep it going man
we're like 20 something away from uh a
drunk stream if you guys want to see
that get your friends in here tell them
to become a member or get a gifted
membership whatever join the Discord
please join the Discord do the community
tab if you remember join the members
only Discord that's big make sure to
like the stream before you leave please
all right it helps the streams out a lot
and I'm pretty sure it's the only way to
grow a live stream
other than that
I don't know if you guys go on Twitter
follow me on Twitter I'm not even
tweeting on there so never mind uh
I might delete Twitter again I don't
know
um like the stream thanks for all the
support guys and we will be back
tomorrow morning
to finish this off
have a great night everyone
peace out dudes and thanks again for
everything
boy